bonjour à tous dans la nuit de vendredi
à samedi les sénateurs ont adopté le
projet de loi sur la délimitation des
régions en clair à l'acte 1 de la
réforme territoriale qui porte sur la
nouvelle carte des super région qui
avait été dévoilée par françois hollande
au mois de juin cependant les sénateurs
avaient complètement dénaturé le texte
puisque quelques heures plus tôt dans
l'après midi de vendredi il avait
supprimé l'article premier du texte cet
article qui porte justement sur cette
carte des nouvelles super région un
rejet qui venait des voix de l'ump des
voix des communistes alliés à celle du
groupe rdse ce groupe à majorité de
radicaux de gauche leur argument est de
là que l'on ne peut pas examiner la
taille des nouvelles super région cette
carte des super région sans examiner les
compétences des deux nouvelles régions
il souhaite donc pouvoir vraiment agir
sur ces régions en deuxième lecture à
partir de l'automne prochain tout de
suite donc retour à la séance était à
vendredi soir au sénat monsieur
président guillaume je vous invite à
présenter votre amendement 235
madame la présidente bien sûr nous
sommes au coeur du sujet l'idée là
encore c'est d'afficher
politiquement quelque chose de très fort
c'est de se dire en 2020 il se passera
des choses nous sommes tous d'accord
pour dire que il faudra des grandes
régions et tous les groupes l'ont dit
l'ump a dit sous réserve de consultation
etc il faudra y arriver
nous avons aussi dit que nous ne
pouvions pas entre deux grandes régions
et les communes et les intercommunalités
laisser un no man's land et autant en
zone urbaine autant dans les métropoles
à lyon c'est le cas il peut ne pas y
avoir deux camps ces généraux à lyon il
n'y a plus de caen ses généraux
à lyon il n'y a plus deux camps ces
généraux le conseil général et peut-être
demain à paris se passera des choses
mais dans les départements ruraux il
nous semble que nous devons garder un
nouveau département un nouveau conseil
départemental
peut-être avec des élus élus au même
mode de scrutin
peut-être qu'avec des représentants des
présidents d'intercommunalités après
tout nous verrons bien comment les
choses se passeront avec des nouvelles
compétences les conseils généraux de
2020 les nouveaux départements ne
pourront pas avoir les mêmes compétences
qu'aujourd'hui il ya de la redondance et
de la superposition en perd de l'argent
n'est pas efficace sur plein de sujets
c'est un président de conseil général
qui vous le dit qui aime son département
et qui a encore envie de rester présente
conseil général mais force est de
constater que devant des évolutions à
faire aussi cet amendement qui est à la
fois un amendement d'appel un amendement
que nous voulons dire avec force il
faudra qu'en 2020 dans les départements
ruraux il reste un conseil départemental
capable de faire des solidarités
humaines et des solidarités
territoriales est capable d'assurer la
péréquation financière entre les
territoires les plus riches et les
territoires les plus pauvres c'est
l'objet de cet amendement numéro 135
que j'invite la haute assemblée a voté
très largement
je vous remercie monsieur président
guillaume
monsieur le président de commission
votre avis
oui madame la présidente
au terme d'un débat nourri
il faut bien que je dise quand même un
certain nombre de choses
les conseils départementaux sont
maintenus en zone rurale
c'est c'est un appel c'est vrai ça pape
caractère normatif parce que on sait pas
très bien ce que c'est une zone rurale
dans un département est-ce que
seine-et-marne et est un département
rural
434 communes rurales sur 5 114
80 % de la superficie et puis néanmoins
on a un million trois cent cinquante
mille habitants avec de vie de nouvelles
alors bon c'est quand même un peu
compliqué tout ça hein c'est pareil ça
ressemble assez bien toutes choses
égales par ailleurs donc mais on
comprend bien le l'objectif c'est de
dire attention
une réforme qui dirait aller les
départements c'est fini
dans une grande partie de l'espace
de notre pays serait certainement pas
une bonne chose voilà donc la commission
a émis un avis favorable à cet
amendement
c'est la commission j'ai bien traduit
le débat
j'ai traduit le débat
merci monsieur le président la
commission monsieur le ministre la vie
du gouvernement sur cet amendement 135
le gouvernement comprend parfaitement
l'objet de cet amendement il s'agit de
faire en sorte que une réponse soit
portée à la crainte de la perte de
proximité du risque zone de relégation
d'un certain nombre de territoires
ruraux dans lesquelles le conseil
départemental joue le double rôle de la
solidarité de la proximité mais je veux
redire ce qui a été dit par le
gouvernement tout au long de ce débat
pour que cela soit inscrit au
compte-rendu bien compris et rien dans
ce texte ne comporte la suppression du
conseil départemental rien
d'ailleurs le présent la république et
le premier ministre ont clairement
exprimé sur ce sujet il n'y aura pas de
suppression du conseil départemental
dans le cas de ce quinquennat il n'y en
aura pas et s'il devait intervenir il
n'interviendrait qu'au terme d'une
réforme constitutionnelle
c'est à dire dans six ans monsieur le
président guillaume je me permets
d'insister sûr ce point parce qu'après
on va me dire que ce sujet n'a pas été
évoqué que le gouvernement n'a pas
répondu donc je réponds précisément n'y
aura pas de suppression des conseils
départementaux avant la fin de son
quinquennat si cette suppression devait
intervenir un interviendrez quand 2020
c'est-à-dire dans six ans au terme d'un
large débat qui permettrait d'évaluer
les conditions dans lesquelles
s'équilibre la réforme territoriale
après qu'on a fait monter en puissance
les intercommunalités et les régions bon
donc c'est très précis ce que nous
disons et ça devrait être de nature
à calmer tous les discours qui sont de
nature alors qu'on veut faire une
réforme territoriale ambitieuse qui est
destiné à renforcer les solidaires les
uns des solidarités et la proximité a
fait renaître des craintes infondées
partout par ailleurs il ya un deuxième
problème que pose cet amendement c'est
que préconisée dans un amendement qu'on
maintient des départements en zone
rurale alors que pour l'instant ils sont
maintenus par tous
et que pour les supprimer il faudrait
une réforme constitutionnelle
revient à poser dans la loi
un sujet qui relève du droit
constitutionnel et qui en l'occurrence
ne se pose pas du tout puisque nous
n'avons décidé à aucun moment dans la
période qui s'ouvre de procéder à la
suppression des conseils départementaux
je comprends que pour un très grand
nombre de sénateurs j'en ai devant moi
qui sont présidents de conseils généraux
cette question puisse être anxiogène
mais nous vous répondons
nous vous répondons clairement je redis
qu'elle est l'argumentation des
intercommunalités qui monte en puissance
une administrations déconcentrées d'état
qui monte en puissance non pas parce
qu'on substitue aux collectivités
territoriales ou à leurs compétences
l'état mais nous déconcentre on de
l'administration centrale de l'état vers
l'administration territoriale des
pouvoirs pour renforcer le tissu
d'écouté l'administration de l'état au
plan local lous faisons des grandes
régions et ce n'est que dans six ans au
terme d'un long débat que vous nous
demandez d'avoir en prenant le temps de
la voir que nous décidons de cela et
pour le faire il faudra une majorité
qualifiée au parlement des trois
cinquièmes puisqu'il faut une réforme
constitutionnelle et à ce moment là dans
la constitution nous pourrons introduire
des principes qui sont ceux des
préoccupations du sénateur guillaume
lorsqu'il présente cet amendement qui
vise à inscrire dans la loi des choses
qui relèvent de la constitution donc
j'ai apporté des réponses très précises
à la fois en droit et en politique et
les ayant apportées
je comprends que cet amendement aura
permis à ces réponses d'être apportées
il avait de ce point de vue là sa grande
utilité politique et je demande par
conséquent le retrait de cet amendement
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur bockel
j'ai écouté monsieur guillaume et
monsieur le ministre avait qu'à
l'instant on ne peut être que d'accord
avec la chute du propos du ministre sur
le risque que constituerait cet
amendement tel qu'il est rédigé d'être
en deçà de la réalité d'aujourd'hui mais
monsieur liste pour autant et on ne peut
que rejoindre l'intention porté par
monsieur guillaume ne jouez pas avec les
mots tout le débat depuis quelques temps
à en toile de fond la disparition des
conseils généraux à terme c'est un des
rares message qui est d'ailleurs passer
dans l'opinion publique que les gens ont
compris donc il est normal vous parlez
de démarches anxieux enfin d'attitude
anxiogène il est normal que cette
question fasse réfléchir moi je ne suis
pas d'un département entre guillemets
rural mais je vais partie de ces
nombreux départements où il y à du rural
dur urbain du rural profond de l'urma du
périurbain et c'est ce que j'allais dire
tout à l'heure à monsieur guillaume mais
bon c'est vrai qu'on a quelques années
pour le faire il devra le faire
comment à l'intérieur d'un même
département faire la part des choses
entre des parties du territoire qui
pourront se voir déléguer un certain
nombre de compétences et encore ça n'est
pas aussi évident que ça en dehors de
très grandes agglomérations et d'autres
parties du territoire où effectivement
le conseil départemental en tout cas
c'est mon opinion devra perdurer quand
vous parlez et je terminerai là dessus
un de perspectives constitutionnel qu'on
ne peut pas régler de loi constitue ce
qu'on ne peut pas régler dans un débat
législatif ordinaire comme
ce soir eh bien
nous sommes quand même
extrêmement
inquiet de cette perspective du fait qu'
il n'y ait pas véritablement de
préparation aujourd'hui on y reviendra
tout à l'heure mais cette loi est en
train de se faire en occultant ce débat
qui aurait dû être au fond entre autres
sujets pas seulement celui là un
préalable à cette démarche est à cet
égard nous serions aujourd'hui beaucoup
plus serein pour aborder ces questions
monsieur bockel monsieur ministre la
parole
mais ce sénateur vaut qu'elle est ce que
nous pouvons juste un instant dans cette
assemblée tous ensemble et sincèrement
avoir des débats qui corresponde à ce
qu'est la lettre et l'esprit des textes
qu'on présente et non pas un débat qui
porte sur les intentions qu'on nous
porte qu'a dit le président de la
république et qu'adil premier ministre
le président de la république et le
premier ministre ont dit nous engageons
une réforme territoriale à quatre étapes
à quatre volets dont le dernier volet
interviendrait en 2020 au terme de la
réalisation de tous les autres ce qui
suppose une réforme constitutionnelle
un monte des intercommunalités de
constitution des grandes régions 3
présentation d'une loi de clarification
des compétences quatre montées en
puissance de l'administration
déconcentrée de l'état et enfin en point
d'orgue en 2020 dans six ans dans six
ans c'est pas dans six mois dans six ans
la suppression des conseils
départementaux
si le parlement dégageant son ca une
majorité qualifiée des trois cinquièmes
parce qu'il faut une réforme
constitutionnelle et c'est dans six ans
donc dans six ans pendant six ans nous
aurons le temps de faire toutes les
études d'impact toutes les démarches que
vous souhaitez qu'il va franchement on a
parlé étude d'impact pendant des heures
vous aurez en six ans la possibilité de
faire toutes les études d'impact que
vous voulez
et nous ne le ferons
le premier mis cela dit en réponse à une
question au gouvernement hier que dès
lors que nous seront garanties contenues
la manière dont le reste de la réforme
s'équilibrera et s'architecture à que la
suppression des conseils départementaux
je le redit au président guillaume
notamment en milieu rural ne viendra pas
créer les conditions d'une rupture
territoriales comment être plus clair
donc il n'ya pas lieu d'avoir peur il ya
tout lieu d'être assurée puisque nous
avons le temps puisque nous avons la
méthode puisque nous avons les
précautions qui permettent d'éviter que
ne se produit jamais ce que vous
redoutez
voilà donc tout cela est consigné au
compte rendu et par conséquent il ne
pourra pas être dit dans cette assemblée
que nous avons préconisé de façon
brutale sans préparation la disparition
des conseils départementaux
il ne pourra pas être dit parce que le
compte-rendu fera foi que nous n'avons
pas traité de la question du milieu
rural que cela n'a pas été évoqué dans
cette assemblée pendant ces débats alors
que je l'évoquais quasiment en réponse à
chacune de vos questions tout au long du
passage des amendements et de la
discussion générale et il pourra pas
être dit que nous sommes dans la
brutalité la précipitation alors que
tout cela interviendra dans six ans il
ya une majorité constitutionnelle pour
le faire au terme de la stabilisation du
dispositif très ambitieux de réforme
territoriale que portent les marges de
gouvernement merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur favier
oui monsieur lui ce mois bien compris
dans les explications qu'il y avait
plusieurs étapes qui était prévu pour
autant dès le texte qui nous est soumis
là il est déjà indiqué de manière très
clair que l'on va vers cette disparition
des départements
dans l'article 12 il est indiqué par
exemple que le mandat des futurs
conseillers départementaux prendra fin
en mars 2020 le mandat à ma connaissance
des conseils généraux c'est un mandat de
six ans si l'élection a lieu en décembre
2015 normalement on devrait avoir des
mandats qui vont jusqu'en 2021 donc
d'ores et déjà ça veut bien dire on
anticipe déjà
sur la fin des mandats des conseillers
départementaux
alors qu'effectivement n'est pas dit
pour autant clairement qu'on supprime le
département mais on raccourcit d'ores et
déjà effectivement leur mandat se veut
dire les choses sont très claires et
d'ailleurs été annoncée par le président
de la république donc je crois pas je ne
pense pas qu'on puisse rassurer
effectivement les les départements et
des élus départementaux sur ce plan par
ailleurs pour dire quand même sur cet
amendement de notre collègue guillaume
je pense que c'est comme un amendement
qui d'abord effectivement très teintée
est très marquée par la proche des
élections sénatoriales évidemment
personne n'est dupe vouloir rassurer les
milieux ruraux les maires des petites
communes rurales que le parti socialiste
aujourd'hui serait prêt serait prêt à
les défendre alors c'est effectivement
un discours tout à fait nouveau puisque
effectivement le parti socialiste depuis
des mois et des mois n'arrête pas de
rabâcher que nous sommes face à un mille
feuilles il faut alléger ce millefeuille
et évidemment à chaque fois on désigne
deux départements comme étant la feuille
de trop et bien aujourd'hui évidemment
c'est un premier recul peut-être une
marque de lucidité face à la montée du
mécontentement dans les départements
ruraux mais pas seulement ruraux
d'ailleurs et fassent aussi par exemple
la prise de position de la soeur de
l'assemblée des départements de france
je le rappelle une une déclaration
unanime pour condamner
effectivement cette réforme et cette
volonté de supprimer les départements
donc c'est effectivement un premier
recul mais cet amendement est
effectivement tout le monde l'a souligné
est très mal écrit vouloir supprimer les
départements ruraux ça veut dire quoi
département aux toiles on sait bien
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
définition du département rural les
exemples ont été donnés là c'est dès
mardi d'autres sont effectivement des
départements qui sont à la fois urbain
et rural donc aujourd'hui personne
effectivement n'est capable de dire ce
qui serait supprimé et ceux qui seraient
maintenues et par ailleurs pour notre
part nous pensons que les départements
ont leur légitimité en zone rurale comme
aux zones urbaines dans une région comme
ile-de-france de 12 millions d'habitants
où on vient de décider par loin
métropole de supprimer toute
intercommunalité
sur la métropole c'est à dire sur 6
millions d'habitants dans cette zone là
il n'y a plus rien entre la métropole et
la commune il ya des communes on a des
communes qui ont 2000 3000 habitants les
plus petites il n'y aura plus rien
effectivement entre ces communes est
l'instance métropolitaine pour le repas
bien nous pensons qu'il ya besoin
effectivement de conserver non pas un
vague concept de territoires tels que
c'est défini aujourd'hui dans cette fois
métropole d'appeler elle aussi mais il y
a besoin de garder des départements fort
parce que les politiques de solidarité
elles sont aussi importantes je le dis
en zone urbaine qu'en zone rurale
aujourd'hui quand on a dans un
département comme le mien par exemple
près de 40000 rmistes bien croyez moi il
y a besoin de solidarité cette
solidarité aujourd'hui ces départements
qu'il accomplisse ses les départements
effectivement qui porte le soutien à ces
populations aujourd'hui en grande
difficulté et c'est pas demain la
métropole qui réglera ce problème
si monsieur favier messieurs ministre
oui quelques mots à l'adresse du
sénateur guillaume asselin présidente
parce que
le ministre cazeneuve a très bien
expliqué qu' on aurait du temps pour
réfléchir à la meilleure façon
d'organiser la solidarité entre les
territoires et notamment entre ceux qui
sont favorisés et ceux qui sont loin
est-ce que la région renforcer les
nouvelles régions pourront assurer ce
rôle de solidarité elles pourront le
faire dans certains domaines pas dans
tous les domaines et pas partout c'est
une évidence est-ce que des grandes
communautés de communes à 20000
habitants ou plus seront à même de se
fédérer et de faire jouer entre est la
solidarité peut-être il n'empêche que
comme ancien prison de conseil général
jeunes et encore il ya quelques semaines
je me pose souvent la question de savoir
comment faire jouer la solidarité entre
plusieurs territoires du département de
l'isère et là je m'adresse vraiment très
particulièrement à didier guillaume
parce qu'il connaît bien l'isère caisson
départements voisins il y avait problème
complexe que nous allons devoir résoudre
et on n'aura pas trop de 6 ans pour le
faire l'agglomération grenobloise va
devenir une métropole et l coupe
carrément le département de l'isère en
deux il ya une partie nord de l'isère
qui va rester département départemental
en partie sud tourner vers les
hautes-alpes une partie vers la drôme
comment faire jouer un conseil
département s'il était décidé qu'on le
maintienne alors que le territoire du
département je répète serait coupée en
deux il faut donc imaginer des solutions
nouvelles peut-être une solidarité inter
départementale entre la partie de
l'isère comprise entre grenoble et
chambéry et la savoie il ya peut-être
quelque chose à inventer du côté de la
drôme et des hautes-alpes aussi tout ça
pour vous dire que les années qui
viennent pourront nous permettre de
réfléchir à la meilleure façon
de faire évoluer le conseil
départemental sa gouvernance comme l'a
dit jean pierre bel sa façon de
fonctionner son mode d'élection est ce
qu'on va vers une assemblée de
communauté de communes est ce qu'on va
vers des entente interdépartementale sur
certains territoires tout est ouvert y
compris une gestion différenciée selon
les territoires du nord au sud et d'est
en ouest donc voila moi je partage
totalement évidemment ce qu'a dit
bernard cazeneuve les conseils
départementaux sont maintenus jusqu'en
2020 d'ici là voyons par quoi et comment
les remplacer s'il devait être supprimé
purement et simplement ce que je ne
crois pas un chez mini ce monsieur temps
donné
merci mesdames messieurs les ministres
oui
d'abord je suis étonné que notre
rapporteur de notre commission spéciale
ne nous est pas rejoint ce set ce soir
c'est vrai qu'il a pris sa mission avec
une certaine distance en tout cas je à
propos de cet article de cet amendement
je vais le plagier il avait dit alors de
la commission que quel état était la
définition du département rural on la
connaît pas si on ne voulait rétablir le
département il fallait le dire n'ont pas
visé les conseils départementaux et il
trouvait que cet amendement était
maladroit puisqu'il parlait de maintenir
des départements définitive alors qu'ils
n'étaient pas supprimées mais tout à
l'heure ce guillaume nous a rejoints sur
notre amendement qui est sollicitée cinq
conseillers régionaux par département
rural et qui disait autant faire de la
politique la politique générale mon
président de conseil général dans le
lot-et-garonne a fait un communiqué
disant qu'il avait signé cet amendement
continuant dans ce style faisant du
théâtre tous les intermittents du
spectacle ne sont pas en grève et je
m'associerai à cet amendement
mais s'étant donné la parole à monsieur
le président la commission
même la présidente monsieur tandonnet si
je ne suis pas digne effectivement de
rapporter au nom de la commission j'ai
dit exactement ce que vous avez dit et
ce qui avait été dit en commission
simplement à la fin j'ai dit peu après
un débat nourri on avait donné un avis
favorable
alors qu'ils avaient tout un tas de
raison de donner un avis défavorable
constitutionnel et autres c'est clair
non mais si vous vous rapportera plenel
moi je vais aller me coucher
on a besoin de vous monsieur le
président en
vient j'ai encore deux trois quatre cinq
six
celles-ci intervenant
oui mais mais c'est d'obliger d'abord
finalement on entend des choses
agréables finalement
cette soirée je parle pas bien sûr
quelques contacts entre les uns et les
autres mais de la part des ministres
donc ça mérite qu'on revienne un peu
dessus parce que moi ce que j'aimerais
c'est une déclaration qui soit claire
c'était déjà clair monsieur le ministre
est déjà pas mal mais il faut encore une
petite faut encore quand même une petite
traduction puisque depuis des semaines
voire des mois la une de tous les
journaux ça a été et dieu sait si on en
a suppression du département le
millefeuille le président de la
république a dit les départements ont
vécu vingt départements vécu vingt les
conseils départementaux ou généraux ont
vécu ça veut quand même dire quelque
chose et on va les dévitalisées le plus
rapidement possible c'est à dire jusqu'à
2017 et en 2020 ils seront supprimés je
sais plus quel était le terme qui avait
été employé
mais c'était en 2020 c'est la fin des
conseils départementaux alors je veux
bien qu'on nous dise aujourd'hui c'est
plus tout à fait ça c'est plus tout à
fait la manière dont on voit les choses
moi j'aimerais qu'on nous dise
aujourd'hui je peux vous confirmer que
les départements vont continuer et qu'il
n'est pas question de les supprimer donc
nous n'avons pas comme objective de
supprimer les départements et je pense
que l'amendement 135 bon il est
peut-être pas très bien écrit c'est un
amendement d'appel pourtant il ya des
cosignataires ils sont pas n'importe qui
dans notre assemblée président groupe
présidents de commissions enfin bref des
gens importants alors quand il met à
partir de 2020 les conseils
départementaux sont maintenus en zone
rurale ça sous-entend qui sont
supprimées ailleurs ont commencé parce
que la zone rurale on peut tous espérer
qu'on sera encore maintenue au-delà de
2020 mais moi j'aimerais mieux que le
sous-amendé dire au delà de 2020 les
conseils départementaux seront élus tous
les six ans alors là au moins ça veut
bien dire ce que ça veut dire qu'on les
supprime pas et qu on les conserve tous
et qui continueront au delà de 2020
puisque jusqu'à 2020 ils seront élus
pour quatre ans et 10 mois à peu près et
puis après eh bien voilà on les
réinstaller pour pour six ans dans des
conditions qui peuvent être un peu
différent dans leur organisation et dans
leurs compétences mais
on a quand même actuellement et ça il
faudrait le démentir nous on n'a pas le
poids que vous avez messieurs les
ministres auprès des médias les médias
pour eux aujourd'hui et les citoyens ils
ont entendu qu'on allait supprimer les
conseils départementaux à 2020 puisque
c'est quand même un objectif un objectif
qui a été fixé un objectif qui a été
annoncé par les plus hautes
personnalités de l'état que le premier
ministre l'a dit ici à plusieurs
reprises il l'a dit lors son discours de
politique générale
d'abord dans la bouche de monsieur
fabius et puis le lendemain il l'a dit
lui-même il l'a même recadrer repréciser
à 2020 c'est la fin des conseils
départementaux enfin s'il ne l'a pas dit
ça doit être dans tous les comptes
rendus de notre assemblée s'il ne l'a
pas dit
le monde qu'on fait ici on l'a quand
même tous entendu alors monsieur le
ministre il ya des instructions
aujourd'hui du premier ministre pour
dire très clairement que les conseils
départementaux ne seront pas supprimées
à l'horizon 2020 et que si vous avez
comme objectif de les supprimer à
l'horizon 2020 vous dites c'est dans six
ans on a encore le temps alors pourquoi
en parler aujourd'hui et pourquoi
aujourd'hui faire croire qu'on va les
supprimer alors qu'on n'est pas certain
de le faire en plus vous nous avez dit
il faudra passer par la constitution etc
enfin ça pose un certain nombre de
problèmes mais on a été les premiers à
le dire quand vous avez annoncé enfin
par la bouche du président de la
république et du premier ministre qu'ils
allaient être supprimés on a dit vous
n'y arriverez pas parce que la
constitution dit un certain nombre de
choses sur l'existence des départements
et des conseils généraux il faut bien
sûr un territoire il faut une assemblée
faut des compétences et donc vous n'y
arriverez pas sans passer par la
constitution on pourra vous donner si
vous le voulez toutes les interventions
officielles à la télévision à la radio
et dans les médias des plus hauts
personnages de l'état qui ont dit mais
si on y arrivera il ya aucun problème
et puis au fil des mois et des semaines
maintenant on se rend compte de la
difficulté alors dites nous clairement
que nous sortons du sénat on va pouvoir
dire dehors il n'est pas question de
supprimer les conseils départementaux
après on verra bien ce qui se passera a
ultérieurement mais est ce que c'est ça
la question est ce que vous n'avez pas
cette intention et à ce moment là et
bien modifie l'article en dessous amende
au delà de 2020 les conseils
départementaux seront élus tous les six
ans et je peux vous dire que les
personnels puisque on voulait les
rassurer des conseils généraux vont être
mais rassuré par ce que vous avez dit
ils vont être heureux on va revenir du
sénat et on va leur dire plus de souci
tout va bien on va continuer à
travailler on aura peut-être moins de
compétences on va modifier nos
compétences bon d'accord on va en
discuter mais au moins les conseils
départementaux vont continuer à vivre si
vous dites cela monsieur le ministre moi
je vous fais la carte en un quart
d'heure en fait un amendement
supplémentaires
on fait un article 14 additionnel un
article 14 additionnel et puis on règle
le problème les départements existent à
l'intérieur de futures régions merci
monsieur de lisier monsieur le ministre
monsieur guillaume l'auteur de
l'amendement non très très sincèrement
monsieur le sénateur de vie chez moi je
ne j'ai beaucoup de mal à comprendre les
raisons pour lesquelles on crée de la
confusion sur ce sujet non je vais vous
répondre une nouvelle fois est
précisément le président de la
république et le premier ministre ont
dit ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure 1 on
veut des grandes régions visiblement le
sénat n'est pas prêt il a supprimé
l'article proposant leur pression nous
voulons des grandes régions de nous
voulons des intercommunalités puissante
parce qu'on considère qu' un émiettement
intercommunale qui n'est pas favorable à
des politiques de solidarité et de
proximité sur les territoires 3 nous
voulons une administrations
déconcentrées de l'état qui monte en
puissance 4 nous voulons des
répartitions de compétences claires pour
éviter les enchevêtrements les doublons
les superpositions notamment entre les
départements et des régions c'est la loi
sur la répartition des compétences et la
clarification des compétences que
présenteront andré vallini et marylise
lebranchu 5 nous considérons que au
terme de cette période à l'horizon 2020
dans six ans
il est possible dès lors que nous avons
fait ce travail de procéder à la
suppression des conseils départementaux
vous nous dites ces gouvernements des
spas psychorigide il entend ce qu'on lui
dit vous nous voulons prendre le temps
du débat est bien des bâtons de ce sujet
nous avons six ans pour le faire nous
vous disons par ailleurs que cela va
faire l'objet d'une modification
constitutionnelle donc le deborah hay
mais notre réforme c'est des grandes
régions des intercommunalités puissante
une administrations déconcentrées fort
des répartitions de compétences
qualifiées et des conseils
départementaux comme un point d'orgue à
cette réforme supprimée au terme d'un
débat voilà quelle est notre démarche
le sous-ministre la parole est aux
prises andy lyon
auteur de l'amendement
même la présidente messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues je retire
cet amendement
mais je voudrais dire au bout pouvait le
reprendre je veux dire plusieurs choses
d'abord je voudrais remercier le
président le président y est donc sa
qualité de rapporteur qui fait un
excellent travail et même s'il est
minuit choix pour faire attention de
rigoler quoi dans la séance parce que
tous ceux qui travaillent là sont des
gens qui travaillent pareil et aussi
bien il c'est de le faire en tout cas
bon non mais je réponds à ce que dit et
alors notre collègue deuxièmement à mon
excellente ami christian favier ça va
les procès d'intention il n'ya pas les
bébés qui viennent de naître les
vertueux ce qui ne met jamais les mains
dans le cambouis et ceux qui nourrissent
des idées politicienne ça je n'accepte
pas parce que le débat sur la réalité je
ne sors pas dit si ça fait dix ans je le
porte ça fait six ans que depuis que je
suis au sénat que je laborde j'ai même
fait une question orale sans débat sur
le sujet on a eu beaucoup de débats donc
ça suffit les procès d'intention moi je
quand si le sujet je vais te dire que
c'est moi je considère que je considère
que tous ceux qui s'expriment ici sont
des gens qui s'expriment avec leur
conviction et avec sincérité même si je
partage pas ce qui est dit j'accepte
qu'il soit 10 par tout le monde terminée
mais pas de procès d'intention justement
est sage de je ne les accepte pas
troisièmement sur ce sujet c'est un
amendement d'appel oui c'est un
amendement d'appel parce que nous avons
peur dans les territoires ruraux que
demain nous soyons les oubliés de la vie
les oubliés de cette réforme mais ça
fait dix ans que nous sommes oubliés
chez pas reprendre les rg ppg pas
reprendre les classes qui ont fermé en
rural je vais pas reprendre les
gendarmeries les perceptions les postes
des bureaux de poste d'agent tdf qui
depuis dix ans en tout fermé et
quelqu'un qui me dirait aujourd'hui
qu'il faut que nous continuions avec les
mêmes conseils généraux c'est quelqu'un
qui penseraient plus à sa carte de
visite qu'à l'intérêt de la population
et à l'intérêt des territoires et je le
dis très fortement et très
solennellement parce que depuis dix ans
je suis au bureau de l'adf je n'ai pas
passé une seule réunion sans entendre
des états et des autres et on l'a déjà
dit ici dans cet hémicycle que les
conseils généraux ça n'allait plus qu'on
n'avait plus les moyens de vivre
que les allocations individuelles ce
tarif de solidarité n'était pas qu'en
penser que la paix là où l'état devait
nous paie 50 % nous en paye que 30% que
rien ne va dans les conseils généraux et
qu'aujourd'hui on a peut-être vingt ou
vingt-cinq ou trente qui sont en
faillite et c'est ce mode est de là qu
en voudrait garder non je les dis déjà
plusieurs fois moi je suis pour la fin
de céder quand ses généraux là mais pour
la création de nouvelles solidarités et
de nouveaux territoires départementaux
plus moderne avec des compétences mieux
répartie et il ya possibilité de le
faire enfin sur les transports quand
dans un endroit il ya trois autorités
organisatrices de transports la région
les départements l'agglomération on dit
que c'est efficace et on dit qu on gagne
de l'argent non et il a été dit pendant
pendant tous ces deux jours pleins de
sujets là dessus donc arrêtons de
vouloir rester figé
ne soyons pas conservateur prenons le
faisant le pari du mouvement mais je
continue à penser que entre deux grandes
régions est la cellule de base qu'est la
commune et même l'intercommunalité qui
serait grave qui serait agrandi il me
semble mais nous verrons et je partage
l'avis du ministre nous verrons en
fonction des répartitions de compétences
que nous déciderons nous puisque c'est
nous qui allons les faire ici au
parlement au sénat et à l'assemblée nous
verrons ce qu'il arrivera et moi je suis
ouvert là-dessus peut-être des intercoms
pour en faire des choses la région
pourra en faire d'autres mais je pense à
l'heure qu'il est avec beaucoup de mes
collègues qui sont ici que notamment en
zone rurale peut être ailleurs nous
verrons bien mais cet amendement d'appel
c'est un sujet que notamment en zone
rurale mais peut-être ailleurs il faudra
sûrement garder un échelon départemental
pas élu peut-être comme aujourd'hui
représenté peut-être par les présidents
d'intercommunalités peut-être d'ailleurs
avec des des représentants de la région
des politiques qui seront capables de
mettre en place des nouvelles
solidarités et si ça doit se faire avec
une élection nous le ferons avec
d'élections mais ce qu il disait notre
excellente collègue et ami eric doligé
c'est très clair monsieur le ministre
dites nous qui aura des départements et
je vous dessine la carte ça montre bien
qu'on a eu un débat tenu pendant trois
jours même s'il a été très intéressant
même s'il a été très intéressant c'est à
dire que je suis prêt à mettre une carte
si vous m'assurer que les conseillers
généraux seront maintenues alors que le
maintien des camps ses généraux n'est
pas dans la loi même si je suis d'accord
avec eric doligé je regrette qu'ils
étaient autant aborder ces derniers
jours au plus haut niveau de l'état faux
créant la confusion pour les territoires
mais moi je veux vraiment vous remercier
monsieur 2010 15,9 et monsieur 2010
vallini mais monsieur 2010 15,9 vous
avez dit quelque chose en sincérité tout
à l'heure vous avez parlé au nom du
gouvernement à la représentation assuré
au sénat
et vous avez été très clair dans ce que
vous avez dit alors moi je vous fais
confiance parce que je soutiens votre
action gouvernementale et parce que je
vous soutiens mais surtout parce que
vous avez parlé au nom de la france au
nom du gouvernement et la parole du
gouvernement elle doit être forte et
vous avez dit très clairement tout à
l'heure qu'il n'était pas question
d'envisager aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui dans ce quinquennat la fin
des conseils généraux ben moi ça me
parle ça me parle et la parole du
ministre on ne remet pas en cause elle
est au journal officiel et il l'a dit à
l'ats il l'a dit devant le sénat et que
nous verrons ce qui se passera après et
moi j'espère qu'après on ne gardera pas
les camps ces généraux comme nous les
avons aujourd'hui parce qu'ils sont au
bout il ne marche pas et si j'en vois
toutes les délibérations que nous avons
fait tout le monde est d'accord pour
dire ça donc créons les nouvelles
solidarités
créons les nouvelle péréquation et
ensemble créons les nouveaux conseils
départementaux les nouveaux départements
qui feront la péréquation et la
solidarité entre les grandes régions et
les la cellule de base qu'est la commune
dans ce cadre là monsieur le ministre je
retire mon amendement j'ai entendu ce
que vous disiez mais je nous
continuerons avec mes collègues de
travail et dans la seconde lecture et
surtout dans le prochain projet de loi
dans le prochain projet de loi nous
travaillerons à redéfinir les nouvelles
les nouvelles compétences moi je ne fais
pas partie de ceux qui signe d'émotion
qui font des grands rassemblements pour
dire je ne souhaite pas que ça bouge moi
je fais partie de ceux qui pensent à la
population et qu'ils veulent non mais si
je parle pas je prends pas pour vous pas
pour vous je parle de l'association dans
laquelle je suis membre je pars de la
solution dans laquelle je suis membre et
je demande à ceux qui travaillent au
niveau des conseils généraux
créée justement ces nouvelles
solidarités et de créer le département
de demain et monsieur guillaume
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues nous reste 33 un moment à
examiner je vais vous faire la
proposition d'ouvrir la nuit afin de
terminer l'examen de ce texte
sans ça nous permettrait de ne pas
ouvrir demain samedi et je pense qu'avec
un petit effort de concision sans pour
autant au béret ni la qualité ni la
nature du débat nous devrions y arriver
dans des délais raisonnables
ils ont fait cette proposition très bien
donc nous continuons l'article 9-1 un
moment 123 monsieur favier
c'était le moment de suppression
il est défendu merci monsieur le sens
l'avis défavorable puisque son avis
défavorable puisque cet article vise à
remédier à la censure du conseil
constitutionnel en organisant une
élection partielle en cas de vacance
d'un seul des deux siècles bidon
départementale donc il fallait bien
trouver une solution on ne peut pas
supprimer cet article merci monsieur y
est
monsieur le ministre mais ma vie
la maman 123
le gouvernement est défavorable à
l'amendement 123
l'auteur de cet amendement soit supprimé
l'article 9 du projet de l'eau motif que
dispositions relatives aux élections
départementales partiel lorsqu'un siège
d'un canton est vacant porte atteinte au
principe de parité le gouvernement a
rappelé à la décision du conseil
constitutionnel du 16 mai 2013 qui a
rappelé qu'ils étaient le principe de
bonne administration des collectivités
territoriales est considéré que
l'obligation pour l'un des membres du
binôme de démissionner dès lors qu'un
autre est empêché d'exercer sa fonction
était de nature à porter atteinte à ce
principe par conséquent cet article la
irait à l'encontre des décisions du
conseil constitutionnel par conséquent
pour cette raison nous sommes
défavorable à cet amendement si monsieur
le ministre deux avis défavorables pour
cet amendement pied pour
merci contre
merci mes chers collègues l'abstention
n'est pas adopté trois amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
e52 rectifié bis ses nationaux mais
qu'il présente
il est défendu je vous remercie
la maman 164 monsieur le président yes
errance rédactionnelles je vous remercie
le 91 n'est pas défendu et ont donc je
vais vous demander l'avis votre avis sur
les 52 bis actifs et glisse à il est
intéressant puisqu'il propose qu'on
appelle un système complet de différents
d'élections pour les élections aux
conseils de au conseil départemental
intellectuellement c'est intéressant
mais c'est un cavalier nos défavorable
et monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
défavorable je vous remercie
le gouvernement l'avis du gouvernement
sur l'amendement de la commission sur
favorables précisé vous remercie je vais
donc métro voilà mans en 52 rectifié bis
deux avis défavorables kippour
je suis une amie d'accord avec vous même
merci des contres
merci abstentions il n'est pas adopté la
maman 164 de la commission un avis
favorable du gouvernement qui est pour
merci contre
abstentions il est adopté
et l'article oui je vais faire voter sur
l'article 9 qui est pour le vote sur
l'article 9 mes chers collègues un vote
sur l'arctique merci contre
abstention l'article est adoptée à
l'article 10 224 monsieur favier
défendu je vous remercie monsieur le
président la commission est favorable
puisque c'est la conséquence de
l'article 9 donc
favorable défavorable oui d'accord très
bien je lui mets aux voix le 124
favorable de la commission est
défavorable du gouvernement
défavorable de la commission pardon
excusez moi deux fois défavorable qui
est pour
les contres
merci maman n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 165 7
un amendement de cohérence
rédactionnelle également notre merci
l'avis du gouvernement
merci je le mets aux voix un amendement
de la commission le gouvernement est
favorable qui est pour
merci contre abstentions il est adopté
même votre sur l'article même votre
merci article aux
deux amendements identiques faisant
levier des discussions communes monsieur
favier
je vous remercie
les surprises dans la commission j'ai
pas sûr que ce soit pour les mêmes
motifs mais on supprime aussi l'article
puisque
conséquences des modifications apportées
par les amendements aux articles 9 et 10
au sein de la loi du 17 mai 2013 auront
pour effet de rendre applicable ces
derniers à compter des prochaines
élections départementales l'article on
devient ainsi inutile si l'avis du
gouvernement sur ces des amendes plus
favorable merci
alors je vais vous voit les deux la
commission est favorable gouvernement
est défavorable qui est pour
monsieur ministe vous voulez vous
exprimer non qui est pour
merci autres
abstentions sont adoptés
l'arctique est donc supprimée après
l'article 11
le mandement 38 n'est pas défendu ils
tendent les 64 michel doligé vous
présenter
messieurs les ministres dont l'article
l'article additionnel l'amendement 64 a
pour objectif de faire en sorte qu' il
n'y ait plus de concomitance entre les
scrutins puisque ça n'a plus de sens
compte tenu de tout ce qu'on a votés
précédemment donc l'objectif serait de
remettre le scrutin tel qu'il était
prévu pour les conseils départementaux
au 15 mars 2015 et non pas à la fin de
puisqu'il n'y a plus de raison de le
faire le même jour que les conseillers
régionaux dans la mesure où il y aurait
un découpage des régions ce qui a
justifié
leur report de l'élection alors que pour
les départements il n'y a pas de
modification pour les départements nous
a bien dit qu'il n'allait pas bouger et
donc ya pas de raison de modifier la
date des élections donc je vous propose
d'ailleurs constitutionnellement je ne
sais pas si on accepterait le reporter
la date des élections
des élections cantonales dans la mesure
où il n'y a pas de modification en ce
qui concerne l'organisation des
départements si monsieur doligé l'avis
de la commission monsieur le président
alors en fait cet amendement il aurait
pu dire il ya on supprime l'article 12
déjà ça puisque pour l'instant les
élections régionales la cause du report
des élections régionales est de
permettre aux régions de ce nouvel
région de s'organiser c'est l'excès et
l'exposé des motifs et on dit ben en
fait le département puisqu'il va avoir
des compétences différentes il faut
aussi retarder l'élection je rappelle
quand même qu'elle a déjà été retardé
d'un an ça va quand même une nouveauté
dans la dans notre droit de reporter
presque deux ans
ça satisfait certains puisque ça va être
presque et un mandat sénatorial ancien
mes anciennes
avant qu'on avant qu'on se réduisent de
nous mêmes pour faire moderne fermons la
parenthèse
donc donc voilà alors c'est quand même
curieux cet amendement parce que je
comprends bien la commission je ne sais
ça devait tron devait être fatigué un
avis favorable monsieur données oui mais
c'est quand même un peu c'est quand même
un petit peu alors donc l'avis favorable
de la commission mais aussi merci
monsieur président monsieur le ministre
se dit j'ai je ne vais pas refaire le
débat ni la déclaration j'ai fait tout à
l'heure mais vous me faites dire des
choses que je n'ai jamais dit hugo
compte rendu de la séance et vous vous
rendrez compte que ce que vous faites
dit en présentant votre amendement pour
le faire accepter quasiment le contraire
de ce que j'ai déclaré total nous sommes
défavorable à cet amendement pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que nous reprenons
à notre compte des dernières décisions
du conseil constitutionnel qui montre
que la concomitance
des deux élections relève disposition
d'intérêt général puisque c'est elle
favorise la participation aux élections
et deuxièmement nous proposons une loi
sur la répartition des compétences qui
va articuler
davantage les choses entre départements
régions et justifier qu'à ce titre on
organise les élections au même moment
pour ces deux raisons nous sommes
défavorables à votre avis le ministre je
vais lui mettre aux voix un avis
favorable de la commission et un avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
messi
qui est contre
merci abstentions il n'est pas adoptée
après l'article aux deux amendements
discussion commune monsieur dantec vous
voulez bien présenter les deux merci
j'entendais il y à quelques instants le
ministre vallini nous parler de la
situation de l'isère mais sur le
finalement on le fait quand on est et on
aurait peut-être besoin demain de faire
un redécoupage
départemental et et je regrettais du
coup que mon premier amendement du jour
ne soit pas passé parce qu'il le
permettait et malheureusement j'ai pas
dû être assez convaincant il n'est pas
passé et un et c'est exactement le point
sur lequel je voulais arriver je
voudrais pas que l'assemblée fasse la
même erreur sur les deux amendements que
je présente maintenant je crois que ça a
été très clair dans le propos du
ministre cazeneuve sur le fait que
c'était une réforme d'ampleur qui allait
donner beaucoup de de pouvoirs aux
régions et aux intercommunalités qui
n'allait pas pour autant d'ailleurs
faire disparaître les départements alors
j'avais demandé la parole tout à l'heure
mais comme
didier guillaume a retiré l'amendement
mais je me disais que finalement on
était en train de dire qu'à partir de
2020 les compétences et découpage des
conseils départementaux s'adapter à la
diversité des situations territoriale
est à peu près ça finalement la phrase
je la mets pour le compte rendu un peu
comme ça vous l'avez au cours de rendu
on peut la réutiliser en deuxième c'est
quand six deuxième séance mais donc avec
un tel pouvoir demain des
intercommunalités autant de
responsabilités est ce que vous imaginez
vraiment sérieusement qu'on va rester
dans le système politique avec des
élections suffrage direct uniquement des
communes et ça n'a pas de sens ça n'a
pas de sens alors il m'est déjà arrivé
dans cette assemblée lors de la lecture
précédente et les pièces en avez souvent
la cruelle expérience qu'on ait quelques
quolibets sur nos propositions
aujourd'hui malgré tout on a des schémas
prescriptif pour les régions auxquelles
on n'aurait pas osé croire il ya
quelques mois encore donc je crois qu'il
ya quand même une logique politique
je crois que on est engagé dans une
réforme importante que globalement le
groupe écologiste soutien qui doit
permettre plus lisibilité de l'action
territoriale de rapprocher donc de
nouveau le citoyen de l'action publique
locale parce qu'il va mieux comprendre
qui fait quoi à partir de là dans cette
logique démocratique
il ne peut pas ne pas voter pour le
président de l'intercommunalité qui aura
le gros des pouvoirs et de vraies
responsabilités sur la vie quotidienne
des habitants de du territoire donc je
vous le demande il est minuit et demi
voilà deux amendements cohérent alors je
détaille pas y en a un pour lyon et un
pour les autres intercommunalités
mais je crois qu'on peut le voter et on
fera un grand pas qu'on fera de toute
manière qu'on fera tout le monde hier
alors plutôt que de le faire dans
quelques mois ou dans quelques années
autant le faire ce soir mais si dantec
je vais demander la ji de notre
président de commission
sur ces deux amendements proposés par
messieurs dantec pas pardon madame la
présidente
les deux amendements d'abord les connaît
bien puisqu'on les a déjà à rejeter
alors les à main de la loi mapam
alors c'est
un nouveau mode d'élection pour les
membres des assemblées délibérantes des
opci à fiscalité propre ils n'ont pas de
lien avec le texte qui nous est soumis
ah ouais tout est dans tout monsieur
empêche de serre bon mais quand même non
pour apprécier si un amendement est un
keita cavaliers le conseil
constitutionnel se réfère au titre et au
contenu du texte amendé
or ce projet de loi n'évoque dans son
titre comme dans ses articles que les
élections régionales et départementales
alors on peut vous trouverez alors c'est
intéressant b donc c'est un avis
défavorable chez les deux amendements
désolé mais
vous êtes déçu mais vous ne vous y
attendiez pas complètement
président monsieur le ministre mais ma
vie a même avis je vous remercie je vais
mettre on voit donc ses deux amendements
en discussion commune le 152 avis
défavorable qui est pour
merci qui est contre
merci abstentions il n'est pas adoptée
même vote pour le 151
même votre mécha collègues même voit
très bien le 6 le suivant l'article 12
le 6 de monsieur nation n'est pas
défendu le temps nous arrivons à l'
amendement à l'article 12 amendements 85
qu'il présente du groupe ump messieurs
doligé
c'est un amendement de suppression
madame la présidente
effectivement vous avez bien compris
depuis que l'on débat de ce dossier
qu'on est opposés à la modification du
calendrier électoral tant que l'on
n'aura pas discuter des compétences
dévolues à chacune des collectivités
alors effectivement dans cet article 12
vous avez énormément de
paragraphes qui vous modifie les dates
des élections dans les différents
domaines que ce soit les conseillers
départementaux ou les régions qui donne
les dates d'élection bien sûr il est dur
et d'élections et je rappelle également
que l'on rappelle que l'élection des
conseillers départementaux prendra fin
en mars 2020 comme je les ai déjà dit à
plusieurs reprises ce qui nous
interrogent toujours et nous interpelle
malgré toutes les explications qu'on a
pu nous donner l'eau j'ai souhaité avec
notre groupe que l'on puisse s'opposer à
cette modification du calendrier et
d'ailleurs nous avons demandé un scrutin
public sur le sujet je vous remercie
monsieur d'origine l'avis de la
commission monsieur le président y est
la présidente le sénat a supprimé
l'article 1er puis par cohérence et
articles de 4 et 6 et donc maintenant
nous sommes saisis scellier d hab un
amendement de suppression de l'article
12 cet article prévoit pour l'essentiel
d'une part le report des élections
régionales et départementales de mars
2015 à décembre 2015 et d'autre part la
réduction de la durée du mandat des
futurs conseillers régionaux et
départementaux en mettant fin à leur
mandat en mars 2020 alors mes chers
collègues je vous incite à relire ce qui
est dit à hope h 30 et 31 2
l'étude d'impact
en ce qui concerne l'avenir des
départements le gouvernement a tout à
l'heure fait part de son analyse il
estime que la suppression de l'article
1er et puisque les plusieurs options
pourquoi 2021 pourquoi 2020 en fait le
2020 c'est en raison de la suppression
des départements de la suppression de
l'article 1er n'implique pas
nécessairement celles de l'article 12
vous avez dit monsieur le ministre tout
à l'heure ce que nous l'avait dit car il
existe toujours un motif d'intérêt
général à reporter les élections de mars
en effet le projet de loi portant
nouvelle organisation du territoire de
la république a également déposé sur le
bureau du sénat
prévoit plusieurs transferts de
compétences en direction des régions en
provenance des départements je relève
que jusqu'à présent parmi les huit
décision qu'il a rendue sur le sujet le
conseil constitutionnel a admis que la
perspective d'une réforme feature où
l'examen concomitants aux élections
d'une réforme par le parlement justifier
un report on pourrait citer 96 pour la
polynésie française 2013 pour
l'assemblée des français de l'étranger
et 2010 dans l'optique de la création du
conseiller territorial
ces réformes avait la particularité de
modifier la composition des assemblées
concernées n'ont simplement modifié les
attributions de ces assemblées
par contre s'est jamais prononcé sur
reports deux fois
en supprimant la nouvelle carte
régionale sénat retirer à motifs
évidents l'intérêt général pour
l'instant en existent ils encore un en
l'état du texte le débat est ouvert la
difficulté tient à ce que les
amendements supprimant l'ensemble de
l'article 200 distinguer les lots visés
ou les scrutins concernés au delà de ce
débat votre commission spéciale adoptée
n'est proche global de la réforme que le
gouvernement nous présente associé de
simplicité de lisibilité
elle a émis un avis favorable à ces
amendements de suppression voilà donc
c'est un avis favorable de la commission
ça nous paraît très lié tout ça si
puisqu'il ya pas de texte on voit pas
pourquoi on modifie le calendrier
électoral
le client y est monsieur le ministre
l'avis du gouvernement sur cet
amendement de suppression oui nous
sommes des faveur de cet amendement de
suppression pour des raisons je veux
expliquer en quelques minutes d'abord
comme l'a dit le président y est au
début de son propos sur est dû le
conduire d'ailleurs avoir le même avis
que celui que je développe maintenant
il y a des motifs d'intérêt général qui
préside le regroupement des deux
scrutins et à leur report ces motifs
d'intérêt général sont les suivants
lorsque les élections ont lieu
concomitamment le conseil
constitutionnel reconnaît lui-même que
il ya une vertu incitatives à la
participation scrutin du fait de la
concomitance du scrutin pour ce qui
concerne son report
le report de l'élection
résulte du fait que nous allons procéder
à l'adoption d'un nouveau découpage
régional au terme des débats que nous
savons d'ores et déjà que nous mettrons
en oeuvre ce redécoupage et qu'il serait
beaucoup plus sain beaucoup plus lisible
pour la transparence du scrutin que le
souhaite a eu lieu dans le cadre du
redécoupage que nous proposons est par
ailleurs nous allons discuter d'un autre
texte
à compter de l'automne qui définit les
compétences entre les départements et
les régions donc il y aura une nouvelle
car il y aura de nouvelles compétences
il y a un intérêt général organisé la
concomitance des deux élections pour
toutes ces raisons nous considérons que
l'article 12 et tellier de l'article 1
de la loi qu'il est une existence
intrinsèque en tant que tel et que tous
les motifs que je viens d'évoquer
justifie qu'on adopte cet article merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur bockel
merci madame la présidente le groupe u10
va voter cet amendement de suppression
totale
la majorité du groupe usé
la majorité du groupe u10 enfin on verra
quel type de scrutin il y aura mais je
ne veux pas anticiper
en tout cas nous allons voter n'est ce
pas monsieur temps donné cet amendement
de suppression excusez moi monsieur lamy
nous pensons en effet nous avons été
constants sur le refus depuis le début
de ce débat de report des dates des
élections
nous considérons que une fois de plus on
met la charrue avant les boeufs cette
réforme ne dispose pas d'un cap
clairement définis au niveau du
calendrier elle fait fi du bon sens en
proposant le contenant avant le contenu
alors même que la répartition des
compétences aurait dû être le point de
départ de toute réorganisation
territoriale cela nous l'avons dit tout
au long du débat et ne sommes pas les
seuls à l'avoir dit les critères que
nous avions mis en avant au début de
cette discussion au niveau de notre
groupe c'était efficience économie
lisibilité pour le citoyen le compte n'y
est pas en résumé et à ce stade de la
discussion puisque évidemment cet
amendement s'il est adopté peut mettre
le point final à la discussion doul le
rappelle mais j'en ai presque fini à
cette heure-ci bien sûr des arguments de
fond manque de réflexion manque de
réflexion en amont manque de visibilité
sur le court moyen et long terme c'était
l'objet de toutes les discussions qu'on
a eues d'ailleurs tout à l'heure encore
à l'instant manque de prise en compte du
travail parlementaire et aussi
d'ailleurs de ce qui nous remontent des
élus locaux ça a été dit par des
collègues surtout le banc sur tous les
bancs voilà le constat que nous dressons
à ce stade et c'est dense et nous le
regrettons d'ailleurs c'est c'est bien
dommage on a un peu le sentiment d'une
occasion manquée je fais partie aussi de
ces élus qui de longue date
attendez cette réforme que ce soit comme
élu local ou aussi à la tête
d'associations d'élus pendant des années
et
franchement on va beaucoup trop vite on
ne prend pas le temps d'aller au fond
des choses c'est bien dommage car une
telle occasion ne se représente pas
souvent et donc c'est d'une certaine
manière avec regret par rapport à l'
occasion manquée que nous serons
plusieurs groupes udi voté cet
amendement présenté à l'instant par
monsieur de chez vous remercie monsieur
bockel monsieur dantec
je dois vous faire part de ma grande
déception par rapport à cet amendement
et la suppression du calendrier initial
ça me rend extrêmement contradictoires
avec la teneur du débat de cet après
midi et je reprends la la formulation de
jean pierre raffarin qui parlait d'une
main tendue qui disait on n'a pas eu le
temps de faire la carte laissez nous le
temps on vous tend la main
alors si on tend la main c'est pour
refaire la carte et refaire la carte ça
donne bien un calendrier est en
cohérence avec ce calendrier il faut
bien rester sur la proposition
gouvernementale sauf si on veut
finalement que rien ne change et que
tout ce qui a été dit cet après midi
n'avait comme sens que de justifier de
commencer à détricoter et nous finissons
à bientôt une heure du matin le
détricotage donc moi je trouve fort
dommageable évidemment cet amendement le
groupe écologiste votera contre et ça ne
donne pas du tout le signal qui a été le
signal de la
de la journée moi j'ai failli voté
avec l'ump sur l'article 1
mais mais justement je me suis dit il ya
peut-être un loup donc je me suis
abstenu pourtant le groupe écologiste
avait été clair nous avions parlé avec
avec monsieur le ministre le fait que
nous considérions que nous allions trop
vite sur la carte qu'il fallait laisser
du temps au débat dans les territoires
moi j'ai trouvé que sur la boîte à
outils
derrière avec les amendements notamment
de michel delebarre on avait fourni un
cadre pour travailler
collectivement dans les territoires et
donc bon finalement je partais à l'idée
que le sénat avait fait oeuvre utile je
trouve même que le débat sur le
département qui fait finalement du
département peut-être la collectivité
constitutionnel qui aura plus le plus
demain la capacité d'expérimentation
d'assumer la gestion différenciée des
nos territoires la gestion différenciée
des territoires si un vieux thèmes
écolos même là je trouvais qu'on
avançait enfin si à la fin de l'histoire
tout ça c'était pour essayer de revenir
au point de départ en supprimant le
calendrier je trouve ça extrêmement
décevant et donc bien évidemment nous
voterons contre et cela change aussi de
notre perception du travail qui a été
fait depuis ce matin c'est l'antec la
parole est un monsieur sa part au nom si
madame le président non je crois que
c'est dans la même logique on reste sur
une logique où il faut déjà établir les
compétences les moyens la fiscalité et
le mode de scrutin suivra je crois que
les choses sont claires quant à leur
concept du département moi j'arrive
toujours pas à me retrouver parce que
quand on a écouté le discours du premier
ministre de politique générale c'était
la suppression du département dans
l'année qui venait dans l'année qui
venait je me rappelle j'étais assis là
au milieu gens tendaient les bras m'en
tombent et et beaucoup tombé de la
chaise à ce moment là quand ils ont
entendu ça on parlait de supprimer le
département dans l'année qui venaient
ils et pratiquement ne plus y avoir
d'élections et puis petit à petit on a
bien vu
écoutez j'ai dû inventer mois on
reprendra les on reprendra le discours
de politique générale quand même hein
ensuite on a bien vu que c'était pas
faisable de faire disparaître le
département comme ça alors quelques
quelques mois avant rappelé le rôle de
deux piliers de chef de file dans le
domaine social et on voit bien monsieur
le ministre les shows départementale est
incontournable dans votre réforme que
l'on souhaite véritablement voir réussir
dès l'instant où allaient tous ses
piliers les piliers ce sont des grandes
régions avec un échelon départemental de
proximité et cet échelon départemental y
doit avoir deux jambes également
amortisseur social et
aménageurs du territoire
ça a été rappelé dans le propos didier
guillaume donc on part sur des bonnes
bases alors un coup dit on va le
supprimer on va pas le supprimant on va
voir comment on s'organise en attendant
au sais pas comment on va le remplacer
c'est pas la peine de faire des
fantasmes pendant six ans d'inquiéter
les populations rurales qui était le
personnel qui travaille fort
remarquablement à notre disposition pour
le service rendu à la population
il vaut mieux aller dans une stratégie
on dira voilà comment on va organiser
les nouvelles solidarités ce n'est pas à
l'ordre du jour c'est la raison pour
laquelle dans la même cohérence nous
pensons qu'il vaut mieux attendre encore
que la carte soit défini avec les
compétences notamment je reviens en
route et au collège qui transférées aux
régions n'ont plus la même vocation que
de rester à un ex long de proximité
qu'est encore le département pour un
certain nombre d'années me semble-t-il
donc cette logique doit aller jusqu'au
bout et jusqu'au bout c'est la
suppression de l'article doux c'est la
raison pour laquelle je pense qu'on ne
peut être un certain nombre à se
rassembler par rapport à cette
proposition
si monsieur savard guy moussi ministre
monsieur savary jeu vraiment je me
permets d'insister sur le fait qu'on ne
peut pas conduire des débats dans la
plus grande mauvaise foi le premier n'a
jamais dit ce que vous avez dit jamais
le premier ministre a dit devant le
sénat a dit devant l'assemblée nationale
que la suppression des départements
interviendrait à l'horizon 2020 nous
avons que nous avons été un certain
nombre à contribuer à l'élaboration de
son discours à le connaître parfaitement
le premier ministre a dit qu'il voulait
faire monter en puissance les
intercommunalités nous allons le faire
qu'il fallait une loi de répartition et
de clarification des compétences madame
lebranchu monsieur vallini vont porter
ce texte devant le parlement qu'il
fallait des grandes régions et que la
suppression des départements
interviendrait à l'horizon 2020 voilà
quelle est la doctrine gouvernement donc
vous voyez dans ces sujets de
l'ambiguïté moi je n'y vois que de la
clarté et ne fait pas à travers la des
procédés de plus parfaite mauvaise foi
qui travestissent les propos du premier
ministre et des ministres devant cette
assemblée des procès qui vise à créer de
la confusion pour ensuite faire des
commentaires de presse qui sont des
commentaires de dénigrement de la
politique de ce gouvernement ce qui peut
justifier de la part de l'opposition
mais utiliser des arguments de bonne foi
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président cher vous avez la parole pas
en dieu ce trio guillaume excusez moi
pardon je ne voudrais vraiment pas
usurpé un titre kids dont je ne suis
absolument pas capable d'assumer les
qualités du président sueur messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues je
suis à la fois surpris choqués et déçus
d'avoir entendu ce que j'ai entendu
jeudi en toute amitié mais ronan dantec
la tribune évoqué cet après-midi et le
compte rendu fait foi le premier
ministre raffarin au nom du groupe ump
à l'ouvert va lancer une main tendue aux
gouvernements et aux sénateurs pour dire
prenons du temps
pour regarder ce que pourraient être les
grandes régions et prenons du temps pour
garder les compétences entre les régions
les intercoms et des départements
prenons du temps
et là vous nous dites il ne faut pas
repousser les élections
donc si on ne pousse pas les élections
et si les élections ont lieu en mars
2015 ne m'explique pas que cette main
tendue était rien à moins qu'elles
étaient réels pour le premier ministre
raffarin mais pas pour tous les membres
du groupe enfin il est absolument un oui
mais on l'a votée en commission mais cet
après midi il ya eu des débats je ne
suis pas en commission monsieur dans
l'hémicycle depuis deux jours sans
bouger et les débats dans l'hémicycle y
compte et donc ce qui a été annoncé cet
après midi c'est de pouvoir ouvrir cette
discussion et si les élections en lui
est en mars 2015 alors évidemment ce
n'est pas possible donc l'objectif c'est
de ne pas de faire des grandes régions
et de ne pas pouvoir aborder la deuxième
loi nous avions proposé nous même de les
reporter jusqu'en mars 2016 pour nous
laisser tout le temps de faire ce
travail est d'arriver devant le peuple
devant les électeurs en connaissions en
connaissant totalement clairement ce
qu'elle est de venir les régions ce qui
est de venir les départements ceux qui
allaient devenir les intercommunalités
et sur quelles compétences et là je peux
vous rejoindre en partie en disant que
le débat sur les compétences il est
important et il faut le voir assez vite
parce que si on n'en parle pas on ne
fait que des grandes orientations et
donc franchement je vous le dis
tranquillement chers collègues si nous
votions cet amendement qui maintient les
élections en mars 2015 alors il n'est
absolument pas possible de faire ce
pourquoi le premier ministre jean pierre
raffarin nous engager cet après midi et
ce pourquoi si j'ai bien compris veut
faire tous les sénateurs et toutes les
sénatrices de la clarté
quelle région quelle carte et quelles
compétences
c'est très clair donc voté l'amendement
en laissant les élections en mars 2015
empêche ce travail et comme nous sommes
tous de bonne foi sans aucune exception
nous sommes d'accord pour dire que si
j'étais en mars 2015 nous ne pourrons
pas faire ce travail donc moi je vous
demande vraiment et je demande à la
haute assemblée de ne pas voter cet
amendement ça ne présage en rien de ce
qui pourra se passer après en rien
chacun pourra mener le débat qu'il
voudra certains parleront des
départements d'ailleurs je constate que
et j'en fais partie on n'a jamais autant
parlé des départements et des conseils
généraux dans cet hémicycle que depuis
deux jours alors qu'il n'a pas une ligne
dans la loi mais il ya eu des
déclarations
la seule ligne qu'il y assez la fin des
élections des conseillers départementaux
mais il ya également la fin des
conseillers régionaux pour qu'elles
aient tout cela sur cinq ans et pour le
ramener en même temps que les émules les
municipales de 2020 ce qui me semble
intelligent de faire des élections de
bloc local donc moi je vous le dis très
franchement si cet amendement était voté
il met à mal il efface la main tendue de
monsieur raffarin tout le travail que
nous pourrions faire dans les mois qui
viennent pour faire en sorte que le
sénat reprennent la main soit la
véritable assemblée des collectivités
locales nous soyons les véritables
représentants des territoires des
citoyens et des élus locaux ce que nous
sommes pour dire quelle architecture
quelle vision politique quelle
orientation voulons-nous dans ce pays le
rapport raffarin krattinger avec des
grandes régions
d oui oui mais je vais y venir à l'autre
bout des intercommunautés plus forte
parce que franchement il y en a est tout
petit moi j'ai dans mon département une
intercommunalité à 930 habitants
certes en zone rurale mais aujourd'hui
c'était de la communalité 930 habitants
bien sûr que si c'est tout à fait légal
dans la loi sarkozy sans aucun problème
ça fait partie non sauf en zone de
montagne pour ces exceptions là et
aujourd'hui on voit bien que cette
intercommunalité ne peut pas fonctionner
et donc entre des grandes régions et le
bloc local il faudra garder nous en
sommes tous d'accord ici
moment venu si le transfert de
compétences n'allez pas jusqu'au bout il
faudrait garder des départements sous
une nouvelle forme ce que nous appelons
les nouveaux départements mais
franchement et je termine là dessus
là-dessus madame la présidente ne pas
reporter les élections nous aurions
voulu blé reporter plus longtemps ne pas
reporter les élections jusqu'en décembre
2015 nous empêche de faire ce travail et
donc nous sommes pour le statu quo et
pour l'immobilisme je sais pas ce que
nous pourrions sortir mais nous ne
pourrons pas faire ce travail en six
mois ne nous racontons pas d'histoires
le sénat élit son président le 1er
octobre et 10 les commissions le 8
octobre et commencera à siéger le 15
octobre expliqué expliquez moi comment
entre le 15 octobre et le mois de mars
avec le plfr le plfss et d'autres textes
nous serions capables d'aller en toute
clarté devant les électeurs en leur
disant voilà ce que nous allons faire
nous irions devant les électeurs en leur
disant d'un voté pour nous et pour durer
bien après pourquoi vous allez voter non
rejeton cet amendement pour le bon sens
de faire le travail merci monsieur le
président guillaume monsieur président
russe
la présidente je pense que c'était la
commission s'était pas malice du tout
non mais attendez pourquoi la commission
a voté l'amendement presque moi j étais
donc je sais ce qui s'est passé la
commission avait estimé qu'à partir du
moment où supprimer l'article 1er
l'article de l'article iv et cetera
c'était un amendement de conséquences
puisque la justification dans l'exposé
des motifs vous le reconnaîtrez c'est à
la fois
c'est à la fois le
le fait que les régions vont changer et
donc il faut qu'elles s'organisent et
c'est donc on reporte les élections et
en même temps l'évolution des
compétences des conseils généraux oh
bien sûr que si on arrive à se mettre
d'accord
sur une carte des nouvelles régions on
reviendra au report mais c'est lié de
choses j'essaie de faire un peu de
logique juridique mais c'est je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on l'a petit peu perdu
complètement c'était tout c'est pour ça
c'est pour ça qu'on avait que la
commission a donné un avis favorable de
conséquence à l'article 12 il n'y avait
pas malice ne vais pas chercher des
choses autres alors monsieur je me
permets quand même je le dis je ne
bougerai plus mais il ya quand même
j'entends des choses on ne parle pas des
départements on n'a jamais parlé des
départements dans ce texte
oui voulez vous lis monsieur le ministre
que vous dites sur les options pourquoi
2020 et pourquoi pas 2021 les une
élection concomitant des conseillers
communautaires et conseillers régionaux
alors que les conseils départementaux
arriveront au terme de leur mandat et ne
sauront pas renouvelé du fait de la
disparition des départements
permettra aux électeurs de s'approprier
ces orientations et de légitimer leur
mise en oeuvre à compter de 2020 à moi
je veux bien qu'on n'en parle pas mais
c'est c'est pas c'est pas au
conditionnel
c'est un indicatif ou au futur non non
non non non oui non mais qui voulez vous
faites autre lecture parce que je peux
continuer comme ça il y en a plein de
pages dans l'est dans l'étude d'impact
justement monsieur le ministre ah oui
mais l'étude d'impact c'est c'est quand
même ça engage le gouvernement voyait
m'excuser alors moi je veux bien moi je
n'ai pas de pour l'instant tant que
président de commission jeunes mais on
parle des départements tout le temps on
n'a parlé que de ça d'ailleurs en fin de
grossesse qui a fait que si on n'aurait
pas parlé
si on avait uniquement dit il faut
regrouper des régions etc je pense qu'on
n'aurait pas eu de difficultés
mais c'est parce qu'on parle sous d'une
manière sous jacente des départements et
ont l'objectif devait être est une
révision constitutionnelle prévoyant la
suppression du conseil général 2020 ça
c'est vrai bon certains disent veuillez
m'excuser bah ça serait peut-être pas
mal que le conseil général ça soit un
groupement de les présidents
d'intercommunalités une sorte de sénat
sauf que c'est plus une collectivité
locale dans toute façon il faudrait
réformer la constitution aussi ah bah
oui au suffrage universel
oui oui oui mais dit oui oui mais énorme
et une assemblée élue au suffrage
universel c'est pas c'est comme ça bon
donc moi je veux bien tout il faut pas
reprocher non plus à quiconque lui
apprenne le terrain parce que faut pas
reprocher à quiconque de penser quand
même et c'est comme ça et on le voit
bien par beaucoup de collègues c'est ils
se disent quelque part
certains disent des départements sont
dépassés quand ils ont présidente
conseillers généraux
faut quand même pas pousser trop loin
parce que mais non pourquoi ils sont
dépassés les conseils généraux monsieur
guillaume parce qu'on les a plombés avec
les dépenses sociales les anciens
gouvernements et les nouveaux les
anciens gouvernements et les nouveaux
c'est ça qu'il a fait bon moi je ne suis
conseiller général c'est vrai que depuis
33 ans et je pense que les conseils
généraux ont évolué et parce que les
régions ont évolué et qu'on change les
compétences qu'on discute des
compétences bien entendu on a fait je me
souviens la loi dit raffarin on avait
déjà discuté de ça sauf qu'on a réussi à
rien éclaircir du tout bon c'était plus
opaque qu'avant bon alors peut-être
qu'on peut s'y mettre vraiment pour
faire des économies et mutualiser et
beaucoup de choses comme ça mais je
pense d'ailleurs que dans notre pays on
réfléchit trop structure sauf qu'il
faudrait mieux réfléchir à l'action
qu'on mène tous les jours et je peux
vous dire qu'il ya beaucoup de gisements
d'économies à faire sans faire des
grandes lois monumental pour 50 ans et
je ne dirai plus rien parce que jamais
c'est le président y est
j'ai donc été saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe ump sur
l'amendement numéro 85 de suppression
l'article 12 je vous rappelle que l'avis
de la commission est favorable et que
l'avis du gouvernement est défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le siècle sur le scrutin
sera ouvert dans quelques instants
est ouvert
je suis
non
le scrutin est clos j'invite les
secrétaires a procédé au dépouillement
vous
résultat du scrutin numéro 2 113 sur
l'amendement 85 nombre de votants 342
nombre de suffrages exprimés 302 pour
l'adoption 166 contre 136 le sénat a
adopté et l'article 12 est ainsi
supprimée et les 13 amendements qui
faisait l'objet d'une discussion commune
tombe
donc nous arrivons
après l'article 12 un amendement
présenté par le quaterback
jeu quelqu'un bac
chers collègues
vous présenté l'amendement 137 rectifié
s'agit des machines à voter
oui il s'agit donc des machines à voter
ces machines à voter ont été mises en
place et quelques années dans une
nombre de communes
soixantaine
rapidement des difficultés ont été
soulevés ici ou là et le gouvernement
avait décidé un moratoire de façon à ce
qu'il n'y ait pas de nouvelles communes
qui décident l'implantation de ces
machines à voter
cela dit il reste toujours aujourd'hui
en france une soixantaine de communes
qui votent avec ses machines à voter
dans mon département les hauts de seine
où nous avons 36 communes onze communes
ont fait ce choix et c'est vrai qu'à
chaque scrutin il y à des contestations
des suspicions et ça crée toujours un
mauvais climat parce que il y à des
candidats qui s'estiment lésés et
considère que ces machines ne sont pas
suffisamment fiables et souhaite revenir
au scrutin classique avec des bulletins
en plus certaines personnes ont quand
même du mal je pense notamment aux
personnes les plus âgées à utiliser ces
machines à voter donc il ya déjà ce
débat sur les machines à voter
d'ailleurs la commission des lois avait
mandaté deux nos collègues monsieur
diagne et lefebvre qui avait fait une
étude sur ce vote électronique et il
avait conclu au maintien du moratoire
pour les machines à voter mais également
avait proposé de ne pas permettre
l'utilisation de machines à voter en cas
de double scrutin
ce que déjà qu'avec un scrutin c'est
complexe le losc en plus il faudra voter
pour deux scrutins sur les mêmes
machines à voter cela va rendre les
opérations de vote encore plus difficile
et donc mon amendement vise à ne pas
autoriser pour le double scrutin qui
arrive
départementales et
régionales
que ce soit en décembre 2015 comme le
souhaite le gouvernement où que ce soit
en mars 2015 puisque nous venons de
supprimer l'article reportant les
élections il y aura un double scrutin et
le même jour nos concitoyens ont voté et
pour les départementales et pour les
régionales est donc cet amendement vise
à ne pas prendre possible l'utilisation
de machines à voter pour ce double
scrutin de manière spécifique par la
suite et j'y travaille je compte déposer
une proposition de loi pour en finir
avec ces machines à voter et revenir au
bon vieux bulletins de vote et isoloirs
dans tous nos bureaux de vote parce que
nos concitoyens ils sont attachés et
parce que cela enlève toute suspicion
quant au résultat des élections mais là
en l'espèce il s'agit vraiment
ponctuellement d'interdire ces machines
à voter pour lui
la commission l'avis de la commission ce
président
là présente comme le vient d'exposer
monsieur calvin bacs cet amendement
reprend une préconisation de nos
excellents collègue alain anziani
antoine lefèvre émises dans le rapport
d'information de cette année
alors cette idée pertinente sur le fond
mais n'a pas vraiment de lien direct
avec le texte en discussion car il
concerne toutes les élections sans
distinction
nos devrions l'examiner dans un texte
spécifique d'ailleurs monsieur kalt and
back a dit qu'il ferait une proposition
de loi je pense qu on l'examinera
tranquillement et je vais lui demander
au nom de la commission le retrait de
son amendement merci monsieur le
président même avis neutre ce retrait
monsieur autres aires
le gouvernement retrait
je vais être consulté je me suis
d'accord pour le retirer je ferme à ppl
mais je crains que le voit d'une ppl ne
soit pas
bébé ne soit pas examiné dans un délai
suffisant pour être opérationnel lors
des prochains scrutins et donc peut-être
qui
me fait pas rire c'est déjà difficile
machine bon on va espérer on va espérer
que la raison revienne qu'une carte soit
proposé que les élections soient bien
décalé à décembre 2015 et que avant
décembre 2015 nous aurons l'opportunité
d'examiner une ppl dans ce sens de façon
à ce qu'il n'y ait pas de contestation
sur ce scrutin ce double scrutin et que
on puisse éviter ces machines à voter
merci monsieur allen va monsieur dantec
vous avez toute une série d'amendements
est ce que vous voulez les présenter les
uns derrière les autres
merci je je je laisse l'assemblée
choisir celui qui est qu'elle préfère
alors donc cinq amendements qui
permettront de réduire l'espace temps
entre le dépôt de la première
proposition écologie sur le sujet et
l'adoption finale puisque travers ce
qu'on a écouté aujourd'hui j'ai
l'impression que certaines de nos
propositions ancien finalement sont
aujourd'hui dans la loi défendu par le
gouvernement
première proposition or là on est passé
peu en avance sur notre temps puisque ça
existe déjà notamment en corse il s'agit
donc dans ces grandes régions plus
fortes de les administrer différemment
avec d'un côté un conseil régional
composée d'une assemblée élue au
suffrage universel et de l'autre un
conseil exécutif élu en son sein plus
l'importance que prennent ces régions je
pense que cette évolution de gouvernance
il ya d'ailleurs dans dans l'amendement
d'autres d'autres évolutions de
gouvernance mai mais moins -
structurantes bas cette évolution de
gouvernance est tout à fait souhaitable
il faut peut-être quand même les veaux
t1 un parent parce qu'ils sont assez
différents voilà à mon numéro un vis de
la commission sur le premier mais
surprise dans la commission
alors c'est
le d'amendements aborde une question
relative à l'organisation interne des
conseils régionaux qui n'est pas l'objet
de l'actuel projet de loi qui vise la
nouvelle carte régionale les élections
régionales et cantonales
alors en plus c'est effectivement c'est
gouvernance des conseils régionaux ont
la monsieur dantec voudrait la qualité
sur le régime applicable à critiquer
territoriale de corse
oui est plein enfin la commission de
demande de retrait aux deux sinon avis
défavorable on va changer le régime même
avis merci messieurs en tête voulaient
retirer 2 al non vous le retirez pas
donc je vais mettre aux voix deux avis
défavorables pour le 152e qui est pour
merci qui est contre
merci abstentions il n'est pas adopté
nous passons 154 rectifié monsieur
dantec donc une deuxième chance avec
cette fois ci donc à une autre
proposition plus simple qui est de
renforcer le rôle des ceser comme là
aussi nous allons avoir une région plus
forte
cette chambre à a vocation à devoir à
devenir plus plus importantes y compris
dans sa composition il ya là beaucoup de
propositions pour une composition du
ceser qui soit plus représentatif de la
population des régions donc un
amendement qui me semble-t-il est
acceptable mais peut-être n'est-ce pas
l'objet de la loi merci mme sison tech
l'avis de la commission je ne veux pas
dire monsieur dantec qu'il est largement
hors sujet mais
néanmoins et une demande de retrait
sinon avis défavorable merci messieurs
les miss mais ma vie je vous remercie
chez antec vous le maintenez pardon à au
vote alors vous le voter qui est pour
deux avis défavorables qui est contre
qui est contre
merci abstentions il n'est pas adopté la
môme en 156 millions tech je note quand
même avec plaisir que je les voie
positive monde d'un amendement sur
l'autre
donc celui là est un amendement qui
correspond aussi au fait de renforcer la
démocratie régionale
actuellement le droit de pétition
locales et restera au sol droit de
demander l'organisation d'une
consultation locale donc la porte est
vraiment extrêmement restreinte et il
s'agit ici de en supprimant tout
simplement les mots le principe est de
renforcer cette capacité
pour les citoyens utiliser le droit de
pétition c'est une manière de revivifier
le débat régional même si évidemment les
décisions ensuite reste aux élus
la commission bas
l'amendement me présente aucun lien avec
l'objet du présent texte puisqu'il a
pour objet de modifier les conditions de
mise en oeuvre d'une consultation locale
donc c'est une demande de retrait à des
faux avis défavorable smith de ma vie
sagesse merci bien je vais mettre aux
voix sur l'amendement 156 un avis
défavorable de la commission d'avis de
sagesse du gouvernement qui est pour
merci qui est contre
merci mes chers collègues abstentions il
n'est pas adopté nous passons à l'avant
dernier le 155 péché dantec
est donc le 155 c'est un amendement là
aussi pour renforcer le droit de le
droit de pétition qui est une avancée
importante pour renforcer la démocratie
régionale et réduire la distance entre
les citoyens et l'assemblée régionale il
reprend je parle à l'intention de mes
camarades un engagement du président de
la république qui avait souligné dans
son discours de dijon en mars 2012 que
le droit de pétition doit être être
élargie reconnu et les assemblées
locales devront se prononcer sur les
sujets que les citoyens eux-mêmes
voudront mettre en débat donc là je suis
dans la ligne des engagements du
président de la république merci
monsieur antec l'avis de la commission
alors versé un moment propose
d'organiser modalités du droit de
pétition pour renforcer les mots
crassier régionales on peut s'étonner de
réduire ses dispositions à la seule
région alors que la démocratie loquace
exercice à chaque échelon et n'est pas
l'apanage des régions cet amendement lés
n'a bien sûr pas plus que les précédents
un lien quelconque avec l'objet du
présent texte donc c'est un devant de
retrait ou défavorable chez ministre
merci deux avis défavorables qui est
pour
merci qui contre
merci mais chaque collègue abstentions
il n'est pas adopté le dernier
sept projets de loi le 153 messieurs
dantec dernière chance mais je me
faisais guère d'illusions sur les
précédents je crois que par rapport à
tout ce qu'on a dit aujourd'hui
sur la difficulté de représentation des
territoires et notamment des territoires
ruraux dans les futurs conseils
régionaux c'est quand même un sujet qui
nous a beaucoup occupé tout au long de
la journée je crois que ça pose à terme
la question peut-être d'un
fonctionnement différent des des
conseils régionaux
donc nous proposons simplement un
rapport donc ça n'engage que peu mais un
rapport évaluant la faisabilité de
l'évolution de la représentation
régionale vers un système bicaméral une
première chambre représentant donc des
citoyens par un scrutin direct et lui
donc dans le cadre de la circonscription
unique à l'échelle de la région l'autre
chambre représentant les territoires élu
par circonscription infrarégionales au
niveau des bassins de vie ça peut être
une évolution des départements ça peut
être à partir des intercommunalités le
rapport pourra étudier la totalité des
possibilités et nous proposons surtout
que ce rapport établissent aussi les
modalités d'expérimentation dans des
régions volontaires je suis convaincu
qu'on ne sortira du débat sur la
difficulté de représentation de
l'ensemble des territoires dans les
grandes régions que par un système de ce
type je ne l'est pas clé en main encore
monsieur le ministre mais je pense qu'il
est temps de commencer à l'étudier donc
à un rapport serait le bienvenu si
l'avis de la commission monsieur le
président y est
demandé au gouvernement de nous proposer
la création de senna régionaux en fait
c'est est-ce que c'est faisable ou
passer des décisions politiques un jour
quelqu'un se lancer là dedans alors
c'est vrai qu'il ya des grecs c'est vrai
qu'il ya des pays qui fonctionne même au
niveau infra étatique avec deux
assemblées une assemblée des territoires
c'est vrai plus ou moins face à senna et
puis une assemblée d'une forme d'une
sorte de chambre des représentants bon
ça peut le concevoir mais y'a pas besoin
de rapports la faisabilité vous fait une
proposition de loi qui on l'examinera
peut-être qu'il faudrait une proposition
de loi d'ailleurs un peu plus que simple
mais enfin bon
mais le sénat
a été intéressée enfin la commission
spéciale or sans doute le sénat aussi a
été intéressé par votre démarche pleine
de l'imagination
mais néanmoins il n'aime pas beaucoup en
plus les rapports
pas trop de rapport parce que ça une
utilité relative mais il y en a car le
fatras des demandes souvent mais nous
avons pensé aussi que ça avait un lien
assez
ténu avec l'objet de notre débat donc
c'est une demande de retraire des fois
un avis défavorable merci monsieur
prison yes mais ma vie monsieur le
ministre
est l'occasion de dire à ronan dantec
telle était l'avis du gouvernement un
amendement nous ne sommes pas favorables
un rapport et nous ne sommes pas
favorables à une seconde assembler
deux avis défavorables qui est pour
merci qu'est contre
merci mes chers collègues abstentions
l'amendement n'est pas adopté je
m'apprête mes chers collègues à mettre
aux voix l'ensemble du projet de loi y
at il des demandes d'explications de
vote
monsieur guillaume
le ministre mes chers collègues de façon
très très courte à cette heure-ci tout a
été dit pendant ces deux jours le groupe
socialiste votera contre ce projet de
loi ce projet de loi était totalement
dénaturé malgré les débats riches de ces
deux jours malgré les mains tendues qui
ont été lancés notamment par le premier
ministre raffarin la main tendue que
nous avons nous-mêmes lancer la
discussion générale nous pensions qu'il
était possible de nous mettre d'accord
en travaillant sur des grandes régions
parce que nous sommes quasiment tous
d'accord sur ces grandes régions qu'il
était facile de nous mettre d'accord sur
le droit d'option pour les départements
d'ailleurs nous avons un petit peu
avancé même c'est parce que nous aurions
forcément voulu que nous aurions pu
avancer sur tout un tas d'autres sujets
ne sont pas les de ruralité nous avons
parlé bref nous avons entendu ce qu'ils
lisent et le ministre et les engagements
du du ministre mais ce texte aujourd'hui
ne correspond plus à rien par rapport à
son origine est ce que nous pensons les
élections ne sont pas repoussés j'espère
que l'assemblée aura la sagesse de le
faire parce que nous pourrons même plus
travailler sur le fond donc nous votre
rencontre je voudrais au nom du groupe
socialiste remercié le ministre
cazeneuve et le ministre vallini pour
leur écoute pour l'heure pour les
positions qu'ils ont prise des positions
fermes des pulsions de clarté
représentant les positions du
gouvernement et en même temps écoutant
les sénateurs sur tous les bancs et nous
ouvrons des perspectives pour pour
l'avenir salué le président y est le
président de la commission spéciale et
le travail qu'a fait cette commission ça
n'a pas été simple puisque la commission
des lois avait démarré et puis après
c'est la commission spéciale mais est
quand même beaucoup d'auditions et je
crois vous avez bien travaillé je que
nous considérons que c'est une occasion
ratée ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
effacé deux jours au sénat que le sénat
ne sortira pas forcément grandi lui qui
est l'assemblée des territoires ne pas
réussir à sortir une carte de région ne
pas songer à sortir d'autres
orientations en même temps nous en
prenons à qu'il y aura d'autres débats
l'assemblée peut-être d'autres débats
aussi au sénat et j'espère que le moment
venu le sénat prendra ses
responsabilités pour offrir à nos
concitoyens une nouvelle architecture
département une nouvelle architecture
territoriale qu'ils souhaitent et pour
conclure je dirai tout simplement que
nos concitoyens ce qu'il est ce qu'ils
leur importe si le service public le
service public c'est le patrimoine de
ceux qui n'en n'ont pas le service
public il est indispensable et peu
importe qui gère qui a les compétences
ce qu'il faut c'est que le service
public soit représentée dans toutes les
parties de notre pays dans les villes
dans les grandes métropoles comme dans
les zones intermédiaires et les zones
rurales et c'est la défense de ce
service public que le groupe socialiste
aura à coeur de défendre dans les mois
et les semaines et les mois qui viennent
pour essayer d'avoir un texte de réforme
territoriale digne de ce nom dans
l'intérêt de nos concitoyens est dans
l'intérêt de la france merci merci
monsieur le président guillaume monsieur
dantec
oui
nous avions commencé cette discussion
dans dans un affrontement
entre entre les uns et les autres avec
des tentatives pour repousser la
discussion de ce texte et puis ce matin
on a eu le sentiment peut-être par
moment où cet après midi qu'il y avait
quand même un certain nombre d'accords
entre les uns et les autres c'est à dire
qu'il y avait au moins un accord sur le
fait de dire on ne peut pas continuer
comme cela que l'organisation de la foux
territoriale de la france d'aujourd'hui
ne permet pas de répondre aux grands
enjeux grands enjeux qui sont
effectivement de répondre aux
territoires en difficulté grands enjeux
qui sont d'accompagner aussi les
territoires dynamiques y compris dans
leurs propres difficultés l'étalement
urbain par exemple est une difficulté
aujourd'hui pour dans un certain nombre
de grandes villes qui pèsent sur sur
l'aménagement avec des conséquences
environnementales fortes et que donc
avec ce constat partagé que nous ne
pouvions plus continuer comme cela que
notamment nous n'arrivions pas
aujourd'hui avoir de péréquation
efficace parce que les territoires sont
trop petits de la vraie péréquation à
l'eal à l'intérieur d'un territoire et
bien que finalement il fallait quand
même vraiment bougé je crois qu'on a eu
beaucoup d'interventions
cet après-mdi dans ce sens sur à peu
près tous les bons et que donc à partir
de là le débat mais c'est le sens de
cette loi a beaucoup tourné autour de la
carte régionale que sur ce point
et ça me distingue de mes amis
socialistes le groupe écologiste est lui
aussi parti du constat qu on allait trop
vite et que la carte telle qu'elle était
présentée propose provoqué beaucoup de
crispation et que se laisser un peu de
temps redonner du temps au temps étaient
probablement nécessaires en ce sens et
nous pouvons leur remercier je pense que
michel delebarre en tant que rapporteur
a fait un certain nombre de propositions
consensuelles pour aider à la
constitution d'une nouvelle carte non
pas comme nous l'avons pu l'entendre
pour ouvrir une boîte de pandore où
chacun chercherait chaque territoire
chaque département chercherait pour lui
même des solutions qui ne créerait pas
de cohérence d'ensemble non au contraire
pour que les uns et les autres se posent
des questions en étant conscience de la
totalité des briques qui pourrait bouger
et avec une quasi nécessité de créer des
consensus je crois que l'expérience
qu'on a dans certaines régions c'est que
le débat avance que ce qui n'était pas
possible il y a encore deux mois sera
certainement possible en septembre ou en
octobre donc c'est se donner ce temps là
avec la souplesse qu'apporte le travail
que nous avons fait collectivement
notamment dans la commission spéciale
était une bonne chose est sûre ce sur ce
travail le groupe écologiste était
plutôt satisfait mais effectivement la
fin de la discussion revient au point de
départ nous sommes de nouveau dans le
blocage dans l'affrontement frontal et
dans le fait que une partie des groupes
représentés ici finalement préfère que
rien ne change
vingt-deux régions pas de nouvelles
compétences pour les les conseils
régionaux pas de capacités de
planification forte et que ça ne
répondra pas aux enjeux pour pour les
français donc moi j'en suis j'en suis
évidemment désolé je suis aussi désolé
que le débat n'ait pas pu avancer plus
sur un certain nombre d'avancées
démocratiques
alors j'entends évidemment le le
président de la commission dire que tout
cela était un peu cavalier je ne le
crois pas je crois que c'était le texte
qui parlait de la totalité des
dispositifs démocratique concernés par
cette loi donc c'était normal qu'on
parle du scrutin direct pour les
intercommunales c'était normal qu'on
parle de procédure référendaire
venant aussi des habitants permettant de
participer à ce débat
général sur sur la taille de main des
régions et je remercie le groupe
communiste d'avoir soutenu une manière
constante les processus référendaire je
pense que là dessus nous nous sommes
nous sommes retrouvés et que donc
finalement c'est avec un peu d'amertume
que je vois c'est de loire partir à
l'assemblée nationale qu'il remettra
évidemment en partie dans le dans le bon
sens alors que le travail collectif nous
avions fait en termes de méthodologie
méritait d'être confirmée par le fait
que nous gardions le calendrier et que
nous imposions à nous mêmes
effectivement un calendrier contraignant
pour arriver à un résultat dans le dans
le courant de l'automne donc le groupe
écologiste à partir de là votera contre
le projet de loi tel qu'il est
réaffirme son adhésion pleine et entière
aux principes de cette grande loi
portée par les deux textes et notamment
par le texte de maryse lebranchu nous y
reviendrons autour du renforcement du
couple région intercommunalité c'est une
loi nécessaire c'est une loi importante
c'est une loi effectivement qui
correspond aux idées et aux propositions
que porte des écologistes depuis de
nombreuses années mais effectivement ce
soir nous ne retrouvons pas tout à fait
la loi que nous souhaitions nous
voteront donc contre merci mais c'est en
teck la parole était monsieur temps
donné
merci madame la présidente messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues le groupe
eut des uc avait une vue positive de ce
texte était parti pour le travail et
malheureusement nous avons été très
déçus par le résultat de la commission
qui n'a pu aboutir à la proposition
d'une carte et d'un texte il faut dire
que le rapporteur n'y avait pas apporté
beaucoup de conviction et je crois que
cet échec est peut-être dû à à sa
position par contre je veux remercier le
président y est qui a su maintenir dans
ces discussions un cap juridiques
sérieux et qui a rapporté fidèlement les
positions de cette commission si on n'a
pas abouti je pense que la procédure a
été mal engagée et je pense que votre
volonté de nous engager dans une
procédure abrégée avait un séparant ces
deux textes uniquement pour retarder les
élections départementales de 2002 mars
2015 a été le défaut de la cuirasse dans
ses textes et pas cette procédure
abrégée on a séparé le le fond de la
forme et du découpage et donc on est
entré dans des positions totalement
incohérent et cohérente le groupe u10 us
et votera quand même en majorité le
squelette de textes que l'on présentera
à l'assemblée nationale
car effectivement il reste quelque chose
de positif notamment l'article 3 qui
apporte plus de souplesse et qui rend la
parole au territoire en permettant des
fusions de région des fusions de
départements et le choix d'un
département isolé de rejoindre la région
de son choix également l'article 7 qui
apporte plus de représentativité aux
territoires ruraux et qui est une
avancée on sait que la fracture entre
les zones urbaines et les zones rurales
ne fait que s'accentuer ça sera un moyen
d'éviter d'aggraver ces fractures
voilà malheureusement on peut tout se
dire aujourd'hui qu'on arrive quand même
un échec et c'est regrettable j'espère
que au moins d'octobre on sera plus
sérieux autour de la table de travail
merci messieurs étant donné la parole et
un wc dooly's et du groupe ump
oui merci madame la présidente remercie
bien sûr me donner la parole et merci
aussi d'avoir présidé cette séance
successive d'hier et d'aujourd'hui merci
bien sûr aux ministres qui nous ont
accompagnés qui ont essayé de nous
convaincre
ils nous ont convaincus peut-être sur
certains points
tout cas sur leur passion et leur leur
bonne foi
merci au président y est également
rapporteur monsieur delbarre le
président y est s'est donné beaucoup de
mal dans un temps restreint pour essayer
de nous faire avancer dans la réflexion
ce qui n'était bien sûr pas très facile
puisque je vous rappelle que c'est un
texte qu'on a eue le 18 juin ou plus
exactement que le qui a été présenté au
conseil des ministres le 18 juin avec un
autre texte que l'on n'a pas encore tout
à fait officiellement ou que l'on a pas
travaillé officiellement donc sur des
textes intéressants qu'on n'a pas
toujours eu le temps de lire dans le
détail ou de retenir tous les éléments
principaux mais toujours est il qu'on a
quand même fait du bon travail fait
désolé de vous le dire même pour ceux
qui regrettent peut-être un certain
nombre de choses mais on a eu le
sentiment qu'on essayait un peu mieux
les départements je regrette qu'un un
amendement qui était de qualité et été
retirée sous je dirais un certain nombre
d'explications qui vous ont convaincu
concernant l'avenir des départements
ruraux mais ceci étant on a quand même
bien avancé sur les cinq représentants
même si ça pose un certain nombre de
problèmes sur le plan constitutionnel
sur le droit d'option est un élément
fort et que rappelait mon collègue ya
quelques instants qui doit être à
l'article 3 qui est un élément important
et essentiel qui doit nous permettre
d'arriver plus facilement une solution
au niveau de la carte que nous allons
travailler bien sûr nous n'avons pas eu
beaucoup de temps mais nous allons en
avoir pour avancer dans ce dossier donc
merci bien sûr à tous mes collègues
quelles que soient les bancs sur
lesquels il se trouve qu'ils ont aussi
approuvé un certain nombre de ces
avancées et collègues également qui
aurait eu parfois quelques critiques à
apporter au texte qu'ils ont bien
ressenti qu'il y avait de la
précipitation et qu'il manquait parfois
un peu de clarté alors monsieur le
ministre pour terminer parce que j'ai eu
le sentiment par tout à l'heure qu'il y
avait quelques ambiguïté entre nous
concernant effectivement l'avenir des
départements et vous nous disiez vous
n'avez pas le droit de dire et il faut
absolument que ça soit inscrit dans les
minutes de la journée ou de la soirée un
certain nombre de points sur l'avenir
des départements donc effectivement je
vais me permettrait je remercie monsieur
yes de m'avoir appelé tout à l'heure qui
avait une étude d'impact que j'avais lu
qui a d'ailleurs été validée me
semble-t-il par le conseil
constitutionnel qui est quand même un
saut important c'est un document qui
accompagne
le projet de loi qui est signée du 18
juin de monsieur manuel valls est le
monsieur bernard cazeneuve sont quand
même des ministres importants dans notre
république et qui donc ont validé les
éléments que je vais me permettre de re
lire monsieur le ministre avec un
plaisir non dissimulé
parce que si je les avais eu en tête
avant mais j'ai deux valises de
déclaration et j'avais pas mener les
bonnes alors ce qui est dit oui j'ai
juste le temps de faire une 29 toutefois
fixer l'échéance des mandats des
conseillers départementaux en 2021 ne
correspondrait pas au contenu des
orientations formulées par le président
de la république en effet lorsque le
président de la république a présenté la
nouvelle carte des régions lundi 2 juin
2014 il a également indiqué que
l'objectif devait être une révision
constitutionnelle prévoyant la
suppression du conseil général en 2020
je continue en outre à l'avenir
l'organisation territoriale dessiné par
le président de la république et le
premier ministre articulera autour des
communes des intercommunalités et des
régions excité département en effet si
zélé que ces élections étaient jusqu'à
présent couplée avec les élections
départementales la suppression de ces
dernières à terme invite à rapprocher la
tenue des élections régionales et les
autres scrutins locaux le gouvernement
met en place les conditions nécessaires
à la suppression des départements
en tant que collectivité territoriale à
terme ce sont l'ensemble des compétences
des départements qu'il conviendra de
répartir entre le niveau régional et le
niveau des opci à fiscalité propre je
vais bientôt abrégé vos souffrances une
élection concomitante des conseillers
communautaires et des conseillers
régionaux alors que les conseils
départementaux arriveront au terme de
leur mandat ils ne seront pas renouvelés
du fait de la disparition des
départements permettra aux électeurs de
s'approprier ces orientations et de
légitimer leur mise en oeuvre à compter
de 2020 la nouvelle organisation
territoriale souhaitée par le président
de la république et le gouvernement en
mars 2020 les élections municipales
communautaire et régional exit les
départements donc je le tenais à le
redire mais quelques collègues du parti
socialiste qui avait l'air le comprendre
pour certains qui n'était pas question
de supprimer les conseils départementaux
alors
non mais c'est un texte qui est quand
même le texte et a servi de base à nous
présenter le texte de loi et qui est
l'étude d'impact qui est une étude
d'impact de très grande qualité
puisqu'elle a été validée donc pour
toutes ces raisons moi je suis très
satisfait de ce travail que nous avons
fait du résultat que nous avons obtenu
puisqu'on est en ligne de mire pas de
réaliser une carte donc on va les voir
sur le terrain mais les différents élus
de nos collectivités pour faire comme
notre collègue d'ailleurs au sein de la
charente-maritime et de ses collègues
qui ont obtenu un vote unanime pour
éjecter la région centre et pour aller
dans l'aquitaine donc nous nous allons
demander effectivement à nos élus avec
qui veulent se marier puisque personne
n'en veut donc ça pose quand même un
certain nombre de problèmes donc pour
toutes ces raisons là nous allons voter
avec beaucoup de plaisir le texte qui va
ressortir du sénat et je suis persuadé
que les députés dans leur grande sagesse
seront y apporter des compléments tout
en retenant les aspects positifs que
l'on a su y met donc merci beaucoup et
merci ainsi nous accompagnerons dans ce
votre merci chers collègues dernier
intervenant sur favier
oui madame la présidente messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues malgré je
dirais le peu de temps que nous ayons eu
pour préparer ce débat je crois que nous
avons eu quand même pendant ces deux
jours d'abord un débat très riche
très fourni avec pour des questions de
fond qui ont été débattus et je voudrais
d'abord me féliciter que le sénat ne se
soient pas soumis au texte initial du
gouvernement ni aussi à la méthode qui
nous a été imposée avec la procédure
d'urgence mais surtout avec cette erreur
fondamentale à mon avis qui a beaucoup
pesé sur nos débats sur le fait
effectivement de commencer à débattre
sur le périmètre des régions avant de
les discuter des compétences elle même
pour ses futures grandes régions et
surtout des conséquences aussi donc de
la mise en place de ces grandes régions
donc chacun sait effectivement elles
seront forcément plus éloignée des
citoyens d'autant que le projet de loi
de m proposé de réduire le nombre d'élus
pour représenter les populations dans ce
projet malgré tout nous prenons en
compte un certain nombre d'avancées que
certains de nos collègues ont évoqué je
pense notamment par exemple à la
représentation minimum de cinq élus par
département ce qui s'est effectivement
constitue une réelle un réel progrès par
rapport à ce qui était proposé dans le
texte initial qui pourrait réduire à un
élu simplement pour part pour certains
départements avec cinq élus on peut
penser effectivement que le pluralisme
sera certainement un peu mieux respectés
et évidemment c'est une proposition que
nous avons soutenu d'une manière
générale pour notre part nous sommes
très attentifs à faire en sorte surtout
que cette réforme ne conduise pas à une
réduction vue je dirais de à une
réduction jeu de l'action publique et on
voit bien que dans cette réforme à
travers aussi toutes les mesures de
récession budgétaires qui sont
aujourd'hui la politique conduite par le
gouvernement on voit bien qu'ils
allaient au contraire une volonté
d'aller vers une réduction de cette
action publique en réduisant y compris
des assemblées élues avec un dès demain
des intercommunalités qui se
substitueront effectivement aux
assemblées communales avec ses grandes
régions qui se substitueront aux
départements et on a bien vu dans ce
débat pendant deux jours combien
effectivement le département continuer
d'avoir une place tout à fait essentiel
dans l'organisation de notre république
et dans la réponse aussi au besoin de
solidarité de cohésion sociale de notre
de notre pays dans tout ça il ya
également une question très importante
qui a d'ailleurs été peu de peu abordée
c'est le besoin qu'une réforme de cette
importance soit je dirais appuyé sur un
véritable débat public avec la
population or quand on aborde une
question une réforme telle importance
qui va transformer pour des décennies un
autre pays il y a besoin évidemment que
les populations soient consultées ces
raisons pour laquelle pour notre part
nous sommes favorables évidemment à une
idée de référendum sur une réforme de
cette importance enfin je crois que
certains peut-être ont pu penser qu'il y
avait eu là une occasion manquée sans
doute je crois que on est très loin des
ambitions qui avait été portée ici même
au sénat au moment des états généraux de
la démocratie locale et je crois qu'il
reste à construire une véritable loi de
décentralisation qui donne plus de
pouvoir aux collectivités locales qui
leur garantissent également des moyens
d'exercer leur leur compétence c'est
malheureusement pas le cas dans les
projets qu'ils sont présentées
actuellement mais nous aurons évidemment
encore l'occasion d'en débattre et en
conclusion en tout cas pour notre groupe
nous nous abstiendrons
monsieur favier j'ai donc été saisi
d'une demande de scrutin public par le
groupe ump sur l'ensemble du projet de
loi il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin sera ouvert
dans quelques instants
non
personne ne demande à voter le scrutin
est clos j'invite les secrétaires a
procédé au dépouillement
si
le résultat du scrutin numéro 2 214 sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi nombre de
votants 336 nombre de suffrages exprimés
313 pour l'adoption 184 contre 129 le
sénat a adopté le projet de loi relatif
à la délimitation des régions aux
élections régionales et départementales
et modifiant le calendrier électoral
voilà pour l'adoption de ce projet de
loi sur la délimitation des régions en
clair donc sur cette nouvelle carte des
super région et sur la première partie
de la réforme territoriale voulue par
françois hollande vous l'avez vu si les
sénateurs ont adopté ce taxi ont
cependant supprimé l'article principal
article qui porte sur la nouvelle carte
des super région l'argument des groupes
ump communiste et rdse à majorité
radicaux de gauche que l'on ne peut pas
examiner travailler sur la carte des
super région sans examiner les
compétences de ces régions c'est
pourquoi ils ont préféré tout simplement
supprimé l'article 1er plutôt que de
modifier de l'amendé comme aurait pu le
faire les sénateurs faut toujours voir
et revoir toutes les séances sur notre
site sur publicsenat.fr très bonne fin
de journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires
il ya 25 ans une poignée de main venait
sceller le destin des deux ennemis
d'hier